Hey, did you guys know your pupils are the last part to stop working when you die? Is that correct? Yeah, they die late. That's incredible. You know the last thing to go through a bug's mind before he hits your windshield? What? His asshole. Welcome to Smartless.
嘿，你们知道人死的时候，瞳孔是身体最后停止工作的部位吗？真的吗？对，它们死得很晚。太惊人了。你知道虫子撞到你挡风玻璃前，脑子里闪过的最后一样东西是什么吗？什么？它的屁股。欢迎收听《SmartLess》。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. So Will, you have expressed that you're not in a great mood today. It is surprising because it is our 200th, so it is cause for celebration.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. 所以威尔，你表现得你今天心情不太好。这让人很惊讶，因为今天是我们的第200期节目，所以值得庆祝。
I had sing you both happy birthday, but it's not a birthday, really. It's just a 200th celebration. I thought it is 200th celebration. You know what? It's a great day for us, and I got to remember remember I had a bit of an okay start and then you have grumpy moments And I just remember this thing of it, which is like Just cuz you have a grumpy start doesn't mean you can't have a great finish. That's right But we don't we don't need a bumper sticker or anything
我本来想给你们俩唱生日快乐歌，但其实这不是生日。这只是第200期庆祝活动。我以为这是第200期庆祝活动。你知道吗？对我们来说这是个好日子，我得记住，我一开始状态还行，然后你就有暴躁的时刻，我只记得这件事的本质，那就是——仅仅因为你开局暴躁，并不意味着你不能有个完美的结局。没错，但我们不需要什么汽车贴纸之类的东西。
Okay, what about you just tell us what the problem is and then we'll do you look like your current. Your current look with your beanies and your beard look like you've got a million bumper stickers and a lot of them say co-exist with different shit on the back of your fucking outback. Does my beanie and my beard put you in a deeper bad mood in my Sally Jessy Raphael glasses? You know why? Because it puts you deeper into Vermont, okay, for me. No, it looks like you're from Seattle. Oh, God, if you could smell my patchouli right now Willie well, yeah. Yeah, tell us what happened. No nothing nothing. I'm just just it's just so much it's just been a lot of admin and admin stuff gets me pissed and and because
好吧，不如你直接告诉我们问题出在哪里，然后我们会——你现在这身打扮，戴着毛线帽留着胡子，看起来就像贴了一百万张汽车贴纸，其中很多贴纸的背面都写着“共存”，就贴在你的福特傲虎后面。我的毛线帽和胡子让我比戴着莎莉·杰西·拉斐尔眼镜时显得更糟糕了吗？你知道为什么吗？因为对我来说，这让你更像个佛蒙特州人了。不，看起来你像是从西雅图来的。哦，天哪，如果你们现在能闻到我身上的广藿香气味的话，威利。好吧，对。对，告诉我们发生了什么。不，没什么，没什么。只是，只是事情太多了，有太多行政事务，行政事务让我很火大，而且因为
domestic administration No, not domestic just work admin and I have a certain way I like doing things. And then when people fuck it up, I'm like, my patience for stuff is like, I go, whew, fucking, what, you've just, things got more, why didn't stuff just go the way, if you let me, my, I thought. This is relatable complaints about having too much work. Is that what it is? Getting a lot of sympathy from the. My, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my,
国内行政管理？不，不是国内的，只是工作的行政管理，我有一套自己习惯的做事方式。然后当别人把它搞砸时，我对这种事的耐心就会，我就会，呜，该死的，什么，你刚刚，事情变得更多了，为什么事情就不能按部就班地进行，如果你让我，我，我以为。这些都是关于工作太多的可以产生共鸣的抱怨。是这样吗？从……那里得到了很多同情。我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、
my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, get inside your head. I'll walk into a room and I'll go, I don't know why she said that. And Scotty goes, you have to catch me way up. Like that's the first thing I'll say. Because I'm so far ahead in my brain. And you just assume that everybody's in your brain. And everybody's frustrated as you are.
我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、我、钻进你的脑子里。我会走进一个房间然后说，我不知道她为什么这么说。然后斯科蒂说，你得把前因后果好好跟我讲讲。就像那是我的第一句话一样。因为我的大脑已经转到很前面去了。而你只是假设每个人都跟你在同一个思维频道上。并且和一样你感到沮丧。
All caught up. Can't they just read your mind? That's right. Anyway, this is wonderful. It is, it's a great, what is this? Yeah, this is supposed to be a day of celebration. Can you believe we've been 200 of these? Yes! 200 episodes!
全明白了。难道他们就不能读懂你的心思吗？就是这样。不管怎样，这太棒了。没错，这太棒了——这是什么？对，这本该是个庆祝的日子。你能相信我们已经录了200期了吗？是的！200集节目！
I can't believe it. 200 episodes. It's hard, it's amazing. Does that mean that it's been 200 weeks since we debuted? Kind of. Is it clean math like that? I think it's a pretty clean math, once a week, yeah. Does it feel like it's been 200?
我简直不敢相信。200集节目。这很难，太惊人了。这是否意味着自从我们出道以来已经过去200周了？差不多吧。数学有这么整齐吗？我觉得这数学挺整齐的，一周一次，对吧。感觉像已经过去200周了吗？
It does not. It does not, it feels like we've been doing it two weeks. Feels like two, okay, yeah, two weeks, sorry. 2000, sorry. 2000, sorry. 2000, sorry. So the math is tough for me, but it does that sort of correlates to what, four years? Well if it's one a week, right?
一点也不。一点也不，感觉我们才刚做两周。感觉像两周，好吧，对，两周，抱歉。2000，抱歉。2000，抱歉。2000，抱歉。所以数学对我很头疼，但这大概相当于什么，四年？好吧，如果是一周一次的话，对吧？
Yeah. That's 52 a year. And we've done 200, right? Yeah, it's four years. It's 200 weeks, right? Yeah. Do you want me to keep saying right? Is that not four years?
对。那是每年52周。我们已经做了200期，对吧？对，是四年。也就是200周，对吧？对。你还要我一直说“对”吗？那不是四年吗？
Well 208, 208, right? Would it be four years? So in two more months it'll be four years. So in two more months, it'll be four years. So like, we're less than smart. No, because 52 times four is 90, what? No. Oh no. You're really getting stumped on this.
嗯，208周，208周，对吧？那会是四年吗？所以再过两个月就是四年了。所以再过两个月，就是四年了。所以，我们智商有点欠费。不，因为52乘以4是90几？不对。哦，不。你真的被这个难住了。
Wait, what's 52 times four? Oh my God. Eight, five times four. What have I done, what have I done? Yeah, it's 208, man! Yeah, yeah. So we're not there yet, but soon it'll be four years. So not four years, but we're 200.
等等，52乘以4是多少？我的天啊。8，5乘以4。我都干了些什么，我都干了些什么？对，是208，老兄！对，对。所以我们还没到那个时候，但很快就是四年了。所以不是四年，但我们已经200期了。
Anyway, who cares? Sorry, just real quick sidebar. With you spending so much time away from home, you must be really building up a little stockpile of crusty socks, am I right? Oh yeah, no, I've got them all standing up. I've turned them into little side tables. Sure.
不管怎样，谁在乎呢？抱歉，插播一个小话题。你花那么多时间离家在外，你一定在悄悄积攒一小堆硬得发硬的袜子吧，我说的对吗？哦，对，没有，我把它们全都立起来了。我把它们做成了小茶几。当然。
Yeah, it's quite a collection. You sure? Of socks. By the way, have we already discussed, we don't need to get too blue, but I didn't know what the sock, I didn't know about the sock method until, I mean I'm 54 years old, I didn't know about it till like two years ago.
对，这收藏可观。你确定？我是说袜子。顺便问一下，我们之前讨论过吗，我们不需要聊得太黄，但我以前不知道袜子的那个方法，我是说我54岁了，直到大概两年前我才知道这个。
Okay. But that you use a sock instead of Kleenex or something? Yeah, it's just genius. It's just, I can't agree with you. Wait, I didn't know which way you were going with that. I know. Honestly, Sean, didn't you think that? I thought he was about to go,
好吧。你是说用袜子代替面巾纸之类的东西？对，这简直是天才。就是，我不能同意你的看法。等等，我不知道你刚才想往哪个方向扯。我知道。老实说，肖恩，你当时没那样想吗？我以为他要说的是，
it's just disgusting knowing that. No, no, I wish I could go back in time. You can toss it in the wash, right? Oh, I would have saved so much. I mean, I guess for you, this is your answer too, if you could turn back time, right? If I could turn back time, my masturbation technique would just be so fantastic. What a bird of a 200-sheet use. I was watching Oprah decades ago,
光是想到那个就觉得恶心。不，不，我真希望时光能倒流。你可以把它扔进洗衣机洗，对吧？哦，那我能省下好多。我是说，我想对你来说，如果你能时光倒流，这也是你的答案吧？如果我能时光倒流，我的手淫技巧一定会好得不得了。200期的用量真是太惊人了。几十年前我在看奥普拉的节目，
and they did this piece. Did she cover this? She did, no, no, she didn't. And she did this piece on this college kid, and they took her whole crew there, and they went inside the college kid's dorm, and with no irony or joking around, they were interviewing this kid,
他们做了一个专题报道。她报道了这个吗？她没有，不，不，没有。他们做了一个关于某个大学生的专题，她带了整个摄制组去那里，他们走进了那个大学生的宿舍，没有一丝讽刺或开玩笑的意思，他们在采访这个孩子，
and his roommates were like, yeah, and he's got this and this, and look, and they opened up his side drawer right next to his pillow and there was tons of Kleenex in there. No. Used Kleenex. And they go, and the guy goes,
他的室友们说，对，他有这个和那个，你看，他们打开了他枕头旁边的小抽屉，里面有大量的面巾纸。没有。用过的面巾纸。然后他们说，那家伙说，
yeah, he gets sick all the time. He gets like sick. Sure, he's always sick every night. And I was like sitting at home going, they actually believe that this kid gets sick. Oh, bless it. Well, he does, he doesn't get, but his dick bar sick. Oh, bless it. Well, he does. He doesn't get, but his dick barfs.
对，他总是生病。他总是生病。当然，他每天晚上都在生病。我当时坐在家里想，他们竟然真的相信这孩子生病了。哦，天哪。好吧，他确实，他不是，但他的鸡巴在呕吐。哦，天哪。好吧，他确实。他不是，但他的鸡巴在呕吐。
Hey, now Will. That's an old school. Shawnee, what's your mood like today on our 200? I'm better now, by the way. I feel much better now that I'm subject to the sun. You should see a little sunshine from your buddies. I know, it's true. I'm good, I'm getting my teeth cleaned later today.
嘿，别这样，威尔。那是老派作风了。肖尼，今天在我们第200期节目里，你心情怎么样？顺便说一句，我现在好多了。我现在沐浴在阳光下，感觉好多了。你应该从你的好基友身上感受到一点阳光。我知道，确实如此。我挺好的，我今天晚些时候要去洗牙。
So I need to clean. You're getting your teeth cleaned? So that's a joyous day for you? It is, I like getting my teeth cleaned. So what happens, you just FedEx him off and then they return him a couple days later? How does that work? You just click those out and put in the weekday set?
所以我需要清理一下。你要去洗牙？所以对你来说这是个快乐的日子？是的，我喜欢洗牙。那会怎么样，你只是把他快递走，然后几天后他们把他退回来？那是怎么运作的？你只是把那些东西按出来，然后换上工作日的套装？
You just have it, do they come to your house or is there a box, a drop box near you? I'm waking up, I forgot to put them back in. Oh yeah, make sure to get your speech impediment. You don't need to put those in, just for an hour, keep them out. No, I gotta leave them in all the time. Abel was late getting in the car.
你只是拥有它，他们会送到你家，还是你附近有一个投递箱？我正在醒来，我忘了把它们戴回去了。哦，对了，确保你的语言障碍还在。你不需要戴上那些，就一个小时，拿出来吧。不，我得一直戴着它们。阿贝尔上车迟到了。
This is this morning. I can't, teenagers, it was part of the thing. And I got into this thing because the kids, I wake them up and then they're like, and then I'm like, we gotta go. And I know we have a recorder. I can't drive to the valet. I love the way they fall back asleep.
这是今天早上。我真是没办法，现在的青少年啊，这就是其中一部分原因。我卷入了这件事，因为孩子们，我叫醒他们，然后他们就，然后我就说，我们得走了。而且我知道我们在录音。我不能开车去代客泊位。我喜欢他们重新睡着的样子。
It's like, hey, great. And I'm like, what are you doing? You're gonna be late for school. You're gonna be late for school. And I'm not in an Uber's expense. I'm trying to like make them feel bad. And I'm like, you gotta get going. Abel goes inside and I'm like, what's going on?
就像，嘿，太棒了。而我就像，你在干什么？你上学要迟到了。你上学要迟到了。而且我可不报销Uber费用。我试图让他们感到羞愧。我说，你们得抓紧了。阿贝尔走进去，我说，怎么回事？
I'm like backing out. He comes around and I go, what did he say? I had to get my rubber bands. He's got the Invisalign, it's like you're shining. I had to get my rubber bands because I got my new rubber bands. And I was like, oh my God, what is happening? Are they dealing with the wax too?
我正倒车呢。他走过来，我说，他说什么了？我得去拿我的橡皮筋。他戴着隐适美，就像你在发光一样。我得去拿我的橡皮筋，因为我拿到了新的橡皮筋。我当时想，哦，天哪，这到底是怎么回事？他们还要对付牙蜡吗？
They gotta put the wax over the hot spots? Archie has to do, cause Archie has the old school ones and then Abe's got the Invisalign, they get to choose. Well yeah, mine's not called, mine's the same thing, but they put those permanent things on the back of your teeth. Those little posts. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
他们得把牙蜡贴在磨嘴的地方吗？阿奇必须这么做，因为阿奇戴的是老式的牙套，而阿贝尔戴的是隐适美，他们可以选。嗯，对，我的不叫，我的是一样的，但他们把那些永久的东西粘在你的牙齿背面。那些小柱子。对，对，对。
So is headgear no longer a thing? Is this the new headgear? It can be. I'll still wear it. It's still a thing, yeah. You have headgear as well? Oh no, that's for a different thing. He's thinking of a different headgear? It can be. I'll still wear it. It's still a thing, yeah. You have headgear as well? Oh no, that's for a different thing. He's thinking of a different headgear, sorry.
所以头套已经过时了吗？这是新型头套吗？可以这么说。我还是会戴的。这仍然很流行，对吧？你也有头套吗？哦不，那是用于不同的事情。他想到的是别的头套吗？可以这么说。我还是会戴的。这仍然很流行，对吧？你也有头套吗？哦不，那是用于不同的事情。他想到的是别的头套了，抱歉。
It's more like a ball that's attached to it. Sean, I don't want to speak for you. No, no, no, you got it. That's right, that's right. Is there a harness at all involved in this? But it's fun. It's fun, on the outside it says Chicago Cubs. Like he tries to make it kind of homey.
它更像是一个连在上面的球。肖恩，我不想替你说话。不，不，不，你懂的。没错，没错。这里面有什么安全带之类的东西吗？但这很有趣。很有趣，外面写着芝加哥小熊队。就像他试图让它显得温馨一点。
I heart the Cubs. Okay, tries to make it kind of homey. I heart the Cubs. Okay, it's enough because we got fancy guests. Let's go, let's go. So let's tighten it up. It's, you know, I figured since it was the 200th episode and just happened to be my turn for a guest, I figured, you know, if it's 200, we need two guests. Right? It's not 100, it's 200.
我爱小熊队。好吧，差不多就行了，因为我们有大牌嘉宾。我们上吧，我们上吧。所以我们要收紧节奏。你知道的，我想既然是第200期节目，而且正好轮到我来请嘉宾，我想，既然是200期，我们需要两位嘉宾。对吧？不是100期，是200期。
Double the power here. Wait, we had to give Sean more math. You're killing it. What's 100 times two? And it's not just two guests. It is a duo. This is a duo that... Cap'n and Neil.
这里要双倍火力。等等，我们得给肖恩出更多数学题。你太厉害了。100乘以2是多少？而且不只是两位嘉宾。这是一个双人组。这是一个……卡彭和尼尔。
Well, very close. And it's not Sonny and Cher either. But we're getting closer. And they're so fancy and they're so accomplished. There's so many awards, there's so many credits, there's so many things that I didn't even, this is the first guest I've not written an intro for. Because it just would be too long.
嗯，非常接近。而且也不是切和雪儿。但我们越来越接近了。他们是如此大牌，如此功成名就。有那么多的奖项，那么多的代表作，有那么多的事情我甚至——这是我第一次没有为嘉宾写开场白。因为那样实在太长了。
Longer than this bullshit. So here they come. Guys, Steve Martin and Martin Short. Shut the fuck up. Hey! Hey! Right? Now, what's the music like now, Willie?
比这堆废话还长。所以他们来了。伙计们，史蒂夫·马丁和马丁·肖特。给老子闭嘴。嘿！嘿！对吧？现在，威利，现在的音乐怎么样？
It's a little bit better. Here come the smiles. It's a little bit better. This is wonderful. Steve, hi everyone. It's a little bit better. It's a little bit better. This is wonderful. Steve, hi everyone. Hi. It's too much. First of all, I have to just jump in. You gotta go?
稍微好一点了。笑容露出来了。稍微好一点了。这太棒了。史蒂夫，大家好。稍微好一点了。稍微好一点了。这太棒了。史蒂夫，大家好。嗨。这太夸张了。首先，我必须插话。你得走？
And say, yeah, I gotta go. I gotta jump in and say how great it was to hear you guys try to figure out what 200 was. And the closest thing... It is four times 50, right? The closest thing I can come up with is that you think 200 is 208, and I'm thinking that you ought to contact NASA and give them this new information.
然后说，是的，我得走了。我必须插话，说说听你们试图弄清楚200是多少，那是多么美妙的体验。最接近的……是4乘以50，对吧？我能想到的最接近的说法是，你们认为200是208，我在想你们应该联系NASA，把这个新情报告诉他们。
Well, you know, we're not trying to trick anyone to think that we're smart. We put it right there in the title. We're smart-less. Which makes me think, how come we're all the less- smart, we put it right there in the title. We're smart less. Which makes me think, how come all the- Oh, I get it. Less is smart. Oh, fuck, oh Marty finally gets it.
好吧，你知道的，我们并不是想欺骗任何人认为我们很聪明。我们把它直接写在标题里了。我们叫Smart-less（少一点聪明）。这让我想知道，为什么我们都是那群更不——我们把它直接写在标题里了。我们叫Smart less。这让我想知道，为什么所有——哦，我明白了。Less是smart（少即聪明）。哦，操，哦，马蒂终于明白了。
But you know- And by the way, four times 52 is like a 85. It's 80, it's in the eighties. Okay, okay. But you know, it struck me with all the brilliant titles you guys have had, have you ever thought about doing Steve Martin Short? It's, and I don't mean this negatively.
但你知道的——顺便说一句，52乘以4大概是85。是80多，在80多左右。好吧，好吧。但你知道，在你们有过的所有精彩标题中，你们有没有想过用“史蒂夫·马丁·肖特”这个名字？我的意思是，我不是在贬义。
This is gonna hurt. No, it's not gonna hurt. It's so obvious. Right. It's like, we've been reviewed that way so many times that we expect more from our audience. Every day I get an email, hey, what about Steve Martin Short? And then I'd see it on any Twitter thing I'm on.
这下要伤感情了。不，不会伤感情的。这太显而易见了。对。就像，我们被这样评价过太多次了，以至于我们对观众有了更高的期待。我每天都会收到一电子邮件，嘿，史蒂夫·马丁·肖特怎么样？然后我在我用的任何推特上都能看到。
What about that? Marty should know that it's so obvious it's also Jason's title of his memoir. So that's why it was taken. No, we've had many different titles. One of my favorite was Two for the Price of Three. Depending on your seat. But what about these titles?
那个怎么样？马蒂应该知道，这太显而易见了，这也是杰森回忆录的书名。所以这个名字已经被用了。不，我们有很多不同的标题。我最喜欢的一个是《买二送三》。取决于你的座位。但这些书名怎么样？
An Evening You Will Forget for the Rest of Your Life, genius, Now You See Them Soon You Won't, the Funniest Show in Town at the Moment, You Won't Believe What they look like today. And number one is Walking, Steve's new book. For Tracy, that's what they call them. It's two years old. Is it?
《余生都会忘却的夜晚》，天才，《转瞬即逝》，《当下镇上最搞笑的节目》，《你不敢相信他们现在的样子》。而第一名是《行走》，史蒂夫的新书。对于特雷西，他们是这么叫的。这书已经两岁了。是吗？
Why do they say new? You know, Wikipedia is just not what it used to be. Yeah, really. Yeah, I know. Also, your dreams are not as informative as it was worth. Marty, do you have excellent lighting or is that new work? You know what, have you ever heard of the word combo? Marty.
为什么他们说这是新书？你知道，维基百科真的今非昔比了。是的，真的。是的，我知道。还有，你的梦想并不像它曾经那么有参考价值。马蒂，你的光线打得真好，还是说做了新医美？你知道吗，你听说过“组合拳”这个词吗？马蒂。
You must admit, I look, I am so angry by the press when they keep saying the word timeless. And I think I have to live up to it on some level. Yeah, sure. The great thing about Marty is he has it all done at once. Right. The hair, the eyes, the nose, the teeth. It's true.
你必须承认，你看，媒体一直用“永恒”这个词来形容我，这让我非常生气。我觉得我在某种程度上必须对得起这个词。是的，当然。马蒂最棒的地方在于他一次性把这些都做好了。对吧。头发、眼睛、鼻子、牙齿。确实如此。
And you heal all at once. You heal six weeks and it's over. Well, you know, I didn't get much from that book about Liberace, but I got a few pointers. I would say that the last time I saw Marty was at the opening of Sean, your play, and I was walking, I think I told this and I was walking by the bar to go upstairs
而且你是一次性恢复的。你恢复六周，然后就结束了。好吧，你知道，关于利伯ace的那本书我没看进去多少，但我得到了一些指点。我可以说，我上一次见到马蒂是在肖恩你的戏剧首演上，当时我正在走——我想我讲过这个——我正走过酒吧准备上楼，
and he was like 50 people away from me and he yelled across everybody, why can't you have talent like that? I have to add a line from your earlier conversation about Kleenex, because Lenny Bruce had a line, it's like the mother, and she goes in her son's room and picks up, she goes, oh, oh look, Sonny blew his nose on the Playboy magazine again Wait a minute, you know still the guys, you know, Selena was on Selena Gomez was on our show a while ago And she said Steve she brought you she brought you up, and she said that, you know, I always wonder if we're gonna keep doing more seasons,
离我大概有50个人的距离，他冲着所有人大喊：“你怎么就不能有点那样的才华呢？”我得补充一句你们刚才关于面巾纸的对话，因为兰尼·布鲁斯有个段子，就像一个母亲，她走进儿子的房间，捡起东西说，哦，哦，看，桑尼又用花花公子杂志擦鼻涕了。等一下，你知道还是那帮人，塞莱娜·戈麦斯前一阵子上了我们的节目，她说，史蒂夫，她提起你了，她说，你知道，我总是好奇我们是否会继续拍更多季，
and Steve says, I wanna do the show, we're standing on the set, and Steve goes, I wanna do this show forever. When do we get out of here today? . . . .
然后史蒂夫说，我想拍这个节目，我们正站在片场里，史蒂夫说，我想永远拍这个节目。我们今天什么时候能离开这儿？. . . .
. . . . . ..... First of all, we pay our compliments to Selena. She's lovely to work with. We love Selena. And she doesn't mind us. Oh, that's Marty. But is someone, do you need to get the door?
. . . . . .....首先，我们要向塞莱娜致敬。她合作起来非常可爱。我们都很喜欢塞莱娜。而且她不介意我们。哦，那是马蒂。但是有人，你需要去开门吗？
You're such a pro. You know what? This is gonna ring 10 times. Cause it's not like having a little. But it's a good location for your audio stuff. You know what, we should have removed it. Uh-huh, is there a little cuckoo bird that's gonna come out at the end?
你真是个老手。你知道吗？这会响10次。因为这不像是拿个小东西。但对于你的音频设备来说，这是个好位置。你知道吗，我们本该把它拿掉的。呃，会不会有一只小布谷鸟在最后跳出来呢？
No, no, no, but keep talking, but just remember, it's not nine o'clock, it's ten. So this incredible duo started with the three amigos, yes? Is Wikipedia correct on that? Correct. Yes, mostly correct. Now, were you aware of each other at all beforehand? Who was in a better position career-wise at that point? Who was who?
不，不，不，但继续说，不过记住，现在不是九点，是十点。所以这个不可思议的双人组是从《三个福星高照》开始的，对吧？维基百科上是这么写的吗？正确。是的，基本上正确。那么，在那之前你们互相知道对方吗？当时谁在事业上处于更好的位置？谁是谁？
Well, Steve was, remember, a major star. Yes. And I was still in the ninth grade. Wait, wait, wait, did you say was? Yeah. Wow. You've still got room to go back. Still rolling, Marty.
好吧，史蒂夫当时，记住，是个大明星。是的。而我还在读初中。等等，等等，你刚才说“曾经是”？对。哇。你还有倒退的空间。还在营业呢，马蒂。
Yeah. Wow. No, Steve, as you know, is a big, big star. But even then, no, I remember being aware of Steve. I met Steve quickly backstage of the new show and he was hosting it. Lauren's show, January 84, it started. It was just one season.
对。哇。不，史蒂夫，如你所知，是个超级大明星。但即便如此，不，我记得我知道史蒂夫。我在《周六夜现场》后台很快地遇到了史蒂夫，当时他是主持人。洛恩的节目，84年1月开播的。只有一季。
And the new show was kind of the idea of SNL in prime time. And Lorne was the host, and Catherine O'Hara was on too. Wait a second, Lorne Michaels was the host on camera? No, no, no, he was executive producer. Yes, Steve was the host. Gotcha, thank you. And so Catherine O'Hara was also on the show,
而《周六夜现场》有点像是黄金时段版SNL的想法。洛恩是主持人，凯瑟琳·欧哈拉也在。等等，洛恩·迈克尔斯是镜头前的主持人？不，不，不，他是执行制片人。是的，史蒂夫是主持人。明白了，谢谢。所以凯瑟琳·欧哈拉也在节目里，
and we were friends with Catherine, so Nancy and I went and visited Katherine and Steve came into his dressing room doing quick change and was very friendly in that kind of icy way that is so Steve. Icy. It was friendly as far as I can go. Yeah.
我们和凯瑟琳是朋友，所以南希和我去拜访了凯瑟琳，史蒂夫走进他的化妆间正在快速换装，表现得非常友好，带着那种史蒂夫式的冰冷友好。冰冷。那是力所能及的友好。对。
You maxed out. But I first met Marty at my house, and he came over to get a copy of the script for Three Amigos. Really? And that's when I first met him. And I of course knew who he was, and I loved, I, since then, you know, I learned more,
你已经发挥到极限了。但我第一次见马蒂是在我家里，他过来拿《三个福星高照》的剧本复印件。真的吗？那就是我第一次见到他。我当然知道他是谁，我喜欢，我——从那以后，你知道的，我了解得更多了，
cause I always enjoyed him, but I also watched him do specials and create new characters, and I realized that his characters are so bizarre, they have nothing to do with humanity. They have to do with like, you know, aliens coming down and saying, hey, I think this is the way they act. Well, thank you.
因为我一直很欣赏他，但我也看他的特别节目并塑造新角色，我意识到他的角色太离奇了，跟人类毫无关系。他们更像是，你知道的，外星人降临然后说，嘿，我觉得人类就是这么行事的。好吧，谢谢。
Right, it's like human behavior done by somebody who's never seen humans behave. Exactly. Right. But so was that part of the thinking, Steve? Was it, you know, this is a fella that mixed in with what I'm doing and what John would be doing, that it would be a great third element
对，就像是由一个从未见过人类行为的人来演绎人类行为。完全正确。对。所以这也是当时想法的一部分吗，史蒂夫？是不是，你知道的，这家伙融入了我正在做的事情以及约翰将要做的事情中，会成为一个很棒的第三个元素，
creating a sort of red, blue, green. Here's exactly what I thought. I gave Marty the script, and I said, now look, when you read this script, and you come across Rick Moranis' name, just cross it out and write yours in. Unavailable. No, no, I was definitely the cheap amigo.
创造一种红、绿、蓝的组合？我的真实想法是这样的。我把剧本给马蒂，我说，听着，当你读这个剧本，看到里克·莫拉尼斯的名字时，直接把它划掉，写上你自己的名字。没空。不，不，我绝对是那个便宜的福星。
I was the, you know, carrot top had said, let me think about it. Wait, what about, and then Chevy was what? Well, no, it was gonna be Steve and Chevy. They were the, I think the original, wasn't it, wasn't it John Candy? I think it was John Belushi. Yeah. Oh, wow.
我就是那个，你知道的，胡萝卜顶（Carrot Top）曾说过，让我想想。等等，那还有什么，切维又是怎么回事？好吧，不，本来是史蒂夫和切维。他们是，我想最初的，难道不是，难道不是约翰·坎迪吗？我觉得是约翰·贝尔苏希。对。哦，哇。
I think it was John Belushi. Yeah. Oh wow. I think it was John Belushi. And then it went to John Candy. I think you kinda know what we were going for there. But anyway, both were unavailable. And then the name Martin Short, Martin Short came up. You know, and after we, you know. And after there was a pause. And then Chevy was last?
我觉得是约翰·贝尔苏希。然后换成了约翰·坎迪。我想你们大概知道我们当时的目标是什么了。但不管怎样，两人都没空。然后马丁·肖特，马丁·肖特的名字就被提出来了。你知道的，在我们，你知道的。在经历了一段沉默之后。然后切维是最后定的？
No, Chevy was in. Me and Chevy were definitely in. It's actually Chevy and I, but whatever. Marty, what was that? Speaking of doing your, you know, Steve was talking about characters, I never knew, like, obviously I was such a huge fan of SNL then and now, but your character Jackie,
不，切维加入了。我和切维绝对加入了。实际上是我和切维，不过无所谓了。马蒂，那是什么？说到你们的，你知道的，史蒂夫在谈论角色，我从不知道，就像，显然我当时和现在都是SNL的超级粉丝，但你的角色杰基，
somebody with the blonde or the white wig. Jackie Rogers Jr. Jackie Rogers Jr. I've never known who that is or was. And I just. I'll tell you exactly who he was. I had done a piece.
那个戴着金发或白发假发的人。小杰基·罗杰斯。小杰基·罗杰斯。我从来不知道那个人是谁或曾经是谁。我只是。我来告诉你他具体是谁。我当时做了一个短片。
An alien. No, a piece on SCTV called the idea that Jackie Rogers Sr. had been killed shooting a special called Old Mother Nature, She Loves Me, and he was attacked by a cougar and killed, and it had been on the show for 11 years. And then they were going to air it. But at the end, I needed someone to pop on and say, I missed my dad, I hope you won't, Thursdays at 7. And I'd seen a picture of Mickey Rooney jr. Who looked albino
一个外星人。不，在SCTV上做过一个短片，讲的是小杰基·罗杰斯 Sr. 在拍摄一部名为《老母亲自然，她爱我》的特别节目时被美洲狮袭击身亡，这个梗在节目里已经播了11年了。然后他们打算播出它。但在最后，我需要有人突然跳出来说，我想念我的爸爸，希望你们不会，周四晚上7点。我当时看到了一张小米奇·鲁尼的照片，他看起来像个白化病人。
I made him albino. Okay. Got it. So wait Jackson. I love that. You have a character backstory Like like your Marlon Brando What's your back Really funny uncle mother nature one Old mother nature, she loves me. It was killed by a rogue cougar. Yeah, there'd be a scene with me singing to a squirrel, pardon me miss, but I never done this with a real live squirrel. But then you saw a cougar lurking and he attacked me and killed me.
我把他弄成了白化病人。好吧。明白了。所以等等，杰克逊。我太喜欢了。你有一个角色的背景故事，就像马龙·白兰度一样。你的背景是什么？有趣的叔叔和老母亲自然。老母亲自然，她爱我。被一只流浪美洲狮杀死了。对，会有一个我和松鼠唱歌的场景，打扰一下小姐，但我从来没跟一只真正的活松鼠做过这种事。但接着你看到了一只美洲狮潜伏着，它袭击了我并杀了我。
Marty, tell them the title of your TV special that I love so much. I Martin Short Goes Hollywood. But that reminded me of something I read years ago of this funniest book title I ever read. And then I thought, oh, I wish I had thought of that. And then I researched it and there is no book called that. I thought maybe I did think of it, but it was kind of a comedy biography of a fictitious actor called I, a actor. I, a actor?
马蒂，告诉他们你那个我非常喜欢的电视特别节目的名字。我，马丁·肖特去好莱坞。但这让我想起了多年前我读过的一个我读过的最有趣的图书标题。然后我想，哦，我要是能想出这个就好了。然后我查了一下，根本没有这样一本书。我以为也许真的是我想出来的，但这有点像是一本虚构演员的喜剧传记，叫做《我，演员》。《我，演员》？
I, a actor. I don't know whose joke that was. And we will be right back. Thank you to Macy's for supporting this episode of Smartless. And we will the right gift. You can shop by price and check out gifts $25 and under or $100 and under. If you're thinking to yourself, my mom has it all. Well, you're in luck. They have a gift list for the mom who has everything. With such a wide variety of fragrances, handbags, tech gadgets, you'll be sure to find something mom will love. I can't wait to go to the website. I'm going to get something for my mother-in-law. She's going to be so excited. And I can't wait to surprise her with something from Macy's. She's
《我，演员》。我不知道那是谁的笑话。我们马上回来。感谢梅西百货对本期《SmartLess》节目的支持。我们将为您挑选完美的礼物。您可以按价格购物，挑选25美元及以下或100美元及以下的礼物。如果你心里在想，我妈妈什么都有了。好吧，你走运了。他们为应有尽有的妈妈准备了一份礼品清单。拥有如此丰富的香水、手袋、科技小工具，你一定能找到妈妈会喜欢的东西。我等不及要去他们的网站了。我要给我婆婆买点东西。她一定会非常兴奋的。我等不及用梅西百货的礼物给她一个惊喜了。她
going to be like, Ooh, it's Macy's. Head on over to Macy's.com slash gift finder to make this Mother's Day an especially memorable one. That's Macy's.com slash gift finder. Smartless is supported in part by Delta Airlines. You know what one of the things about a great trip is? It's not just the place you're going, but actually going and coming home from the trip. That's when you're absorbing all those memories. That's when you're hearkening back to that amazing experience you had with your loved one, your family, your friend. You got some nice wifi going, you got some great food and drinks.
会说，哦，是梅西百货。快前往Macy.com/giftfinder，让这个母亲节变得格外难忘。网址是Macy.com/giftfinder。《SmartLess》部分内容由达美航空赞助播出。你知道一次美妙旅行的关键之一是什么吗？不仅是你要去的地方，实际上还有去和从旅行中回家的过程。那是你吸收所有这些记忆的时候。那是你回味你与爱人、家人、朋友经历的那些美妙体验的时候。你连上了不错的Wi-Fi，还有美味的食物和饮品。
When you think about it, half the trips you take are trips home. That is why Delta Airlines tries to make you feel at home long before you even get there. Delta Airlines has created an industry-leading flying experience curated to fit your needs. They have implemented sustainable alternatives for in-flight dining like plant-based dishes, bamboo cutlery, and organic gluten-free nutrient-packed snacks. Aside from their tasty snacks, they have premium food and beverage options to enjoy while you comb through their 1,000 hours of in-flight entertainment. And if you're a SkyMiles member like me, and I am a long-time SkyMiles member, sit back and enjoy fast, free Delta Sync Wi-Fi on your trip.
仔细想想，你的一半旅行都是回家之旅。这就是为什么达美航空试图让你在到达之前很久就感受到家的温暖。达美航空打造了行业领先的飞行体验，旨在满足您的需求。他们为机上餐饮实施了可持续的替代方案，如植物性菜肴、竹制餐具和有机无麸质营养零食。除了美味的零食，他们还提供优质的食品和饮料选择，供您在浏览1000小时的机上娱乐节目时享用。如果你和我一样是SkyMiles会员，而且我长期以来一直是SkyMiles会员，那就坐下来，在旅途中享受快速、免费的Delta Sync Wi-Fi吧。
Delta Airlines believes you should feel at home even if you're 30,000 feet above it. Learn more at delta.com. Thanks to Viori for supporting the show. If you're sick and tired of traditional workout gear, Viori has you covered. Everything has been designed to work out in, but doesn't look or feel like it. They've drawn inspiration from the coastal California lifestyle to create versatile pieces for everyday wear. We have been fans of Viori for a long time, so I'm excited to tell you why. The Men's Sunday Performance Jogger is one of my favorites. These joggers are made from premium recycled performance stretch fabric that offer equal
达美航空相信，即使身处3万英尺的高空，你也应该感到宾至如归。了解更多请访问delta.com。感谢Viori对本期节目的支持。如果你对传统的健身装备感到厌倦，Viori能满足你的需求。每件产品都旨在适合运动时穿着，但看起来和穿起来却一点也不像运动服。他们从加州海岸的生活方式中汲取灵感，打造出适合日常穿着的多功能单品。我们一直是Viori的粉丝，所以我很高兴告诉你们原因。男士周日高性能慢跑裤是我的最爱之一。这些慢跑裤采用优质回收高性能弹力面料制成，兼具
parts of style and comfort. All of their stuff, including the Men's Sunday Performance Jogger, are just such easygoing, fantastic pieces to wear. I am literally wearing the Metapan right now. And I'm wearing it, they're easy to PCAST in. So I get my PCAST on, then I'm gonna do a couple Zoom meetings, then I'm gonna go for a lunch,
风格与舒适度。他们的所有产品，包括男士周日高性能慢跑裤，都是如此随性、极佳的穿搭单品。我现在身上就穿着Metapan。我正穿着它，穿着它做播客非常轻松。所以我开始录播客，然后我要开几个Zoom会议，接着我要去吃个午饭，
I might go hit some golf balls, and then I'm gonna come home and just chillax. Nothing says chillax like the Metapan or the Sunday performance joker. Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up SmartList listener with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash SmartList. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash SmartList. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping
我可能会去打几个高尔夫球，然后回家放松一下。没有什么比Metapan或周日高性能慢跑裤更能代表“放松”了。Viori是对你幸福的一项投资，他们为SmartList听众提供Viori.com/SmartList首单八折优惠。网址是V-U-O-R-I点com斜杠SmartList。你不仅可以享受首次购买八折优惠，还可以享受
on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to viore.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viore Clothing. And now back to the show. Was it clear to you guys doing that first project that there was going to be a long life to this friendship and this work collaboration,
所有美国境内超过75美元订单的免运费和免费退货服务。访问viore.com/smartless，探索Viori服饰的多功能性。现在回到节目中。你们在做那个第一个项目时，是否清楚这段友谊和工作合作关系会持续很长时间，
or did that just kind of grow on its own? No, I mean, I think it happens when you're working together. I mean, sometimes, as we all know, you do, you know, you're in Romania with a group of people for three months and you make a film and then you never, ever see them again. But with Steve, I thought, no to I want to keep this going. You know I want to I want to so we would do Amigo at dinners and go ahead. Can you see me raising my hand? Yeah go for it Steve. No I was just saying that you know you're
还是说这只是自然而然地发展起来的？不，我的意思是，我认为这发生在你们一起工作的时候。我的意思是，有时，正如我们所知，你在罗马尼亚和一群人呆了三个月拍了一部电影，然后你就再也见不到他们了。但对于史蒂夫，我想，不，我想让它继续下去。你知道我想，我想——所以我们在《福星高照》晚宴上会，接着说。你能看见我举手吗？是的，请便，史蒂夫。不，我只是想说，你知道，你
right usually work with somebody then you never see them again but in this case we continued to work together kind of coincidentally through Father the Bride movies. And did we do another movie together, is that it? Yeah, we did, but that's not, I think the point of it is. What was it? No, no, we did Prince of Egypt. Father the Bride too.
说的对，通常和某人合作后就再也见不到他们了，但在这种情况下，我们通过《新岳父大人》系列电影，某种程度上巧合地继续合作了。我们还一起拍了另一部电影吗，就这样？对，我们拍了，但这不是，我想重点不在这里。是什么？不，不，我们拍了《埃及王子》。《新岳父大人2》。
Oh yeah, you're right, yeah, yeah. And the scenes that were cut from Schindler's. No. No. That you were not supposed to talk about Marty. You know you're not supposed to mention it. Sorry. Just tonally, tonally it was not.
哦，对，没错，对，对。还有从《辛德勒的名单》里剪掉的那些场景。不。不。那是你本来不该提的，马蒂。你知道你不该提那个的。抱歉。只是从基调上来说，从基调上来说，那不是。
It was a swing. No, no, no, but Steve, Steve, Father of the Bride was five years after Three Amigos. We continued to be great friends and we grew up together. Yes, that's true. Yeah. Well, it's like you guys,
那是一次尝试。不，不，不，但是史蒂夫，史蒂夫，《新岳父大人》是在《三个福星高照》五年后拍的。我们一直都是好朋友，我们一起成长。是的，这倒真的。嗯，就像你们两个，
you're constantly riffing off each other. It's fun. And then when you work together, you start doing that all the time, and then you develop a kind of a, not only a kinship, but a style. And you guys had, and you guys also, right, you have a style and you have,
你们一直在互相接梗。这很有趣。然后当你们一起工作时，你们开始一直这样，然后你们培养出了一种，不仅是亲属般的情谊，还有一种风格。而且你们有，你们也有，对吧，你们有自己的风格，而且
socially you have a lot of friends, right, in common. So you're sort of in the same circles. You're kind of in each other's orbits and on a lot of levels, right? Well, let me add something. Only Marty has friends. Right. Right.
在社交上你们有很多共同的朋友，对吧。所以你们基本上在同一个圈子里。你在彼此的轨道上，在很多层面上，对吧？好吧，让我补充一点。只有马蒂有朋友。对，对。
That's my problem with these two. I benefit from his friends. Yeah, yeah. That's not true. But he's very social. Everybody wants to be with Marty, and I've told this before. I'd say, if we're, for example, or someone is plotting a dinner party in Hollywood,
这就是我跟这两个家伙的问题所在。我沾了他朋友的光。对，对。这不是真的。但他很擅长社交。每个人都想和马蒂在一起，我以前也说过。我会说，如果我们，举个例子，或者有人在好莱坞策划一场晚宴，
and you invite these people and you invite Marty, and if Marty can't come, you cancel the party. Marty is the party. Marty party. Marty's party. But back then, and certainly after the success of Three Amigos, you guys could have, if you wanted to, start to generate your own sort of two-hander kind of
你邀请了这些人，你邀请了马蒂，如果马蒂来不了，你就取消派对。马蒂就是派对本身。马蒂派对。马蒂的派对。但当时，当然在《三个福星高照》成功之后，如果你们愿意的话，你们本可以开始打造你们自己的那种双人组合的
vehicles, much like you guys are doing today with your live stuff. Did you think about it? Did that start? No, Steve was a massive movie star, and I was just kind of there. While he was doing Roxanne, I was doing you know, doing the love boat reunion or something, so it wasn't always equal.
作品，就像你们今天用你们的现场演出所做的那样。你们考虑过吗？那是从那时候开始的吗？不，史蒂夫是个超级大电影明星，而我只是个打酱油的。当他在拍《罗克珊娜》时，我在做，你知道的，做《爱之船》重聚节目什么的，所以并不总是平等的。
And I think it was, as Steve said, it just so happened that we were both cast in Father the Bride and the Father Bride 2 and then other things. But it wasn't until around 2011 that we were asked to interview each other on stage for the closing of the Just For Last Comedy Festival in Chicago, and that was successful, and that evolved into our live show. Oh, so that was the impetus for this whole other thing that you guys had created. Yes, right.
我想，正如史蒂夫所说，这纯粹是因为我们俩都被选中出演了《新岳父大人》、《新岳父大人2》以及其他一些作品。直到2011年左右，我们才被邀请在芝加哥“Just For Laughs”喜剧节闭幕式上在舞台上互相采访，那很成功，并演变成了我们的现场演出。哦，所以那是你们创造的另一个全新事物的契机。是的，没错。
But I have to add something, and Jason said, after the success of Three Amigos, dot dot dot, you really mean 20 years after the success of Three Amigos, dot dot dot, you really mean 20 years after the success, the Three Amigos, did it become a success? It was a minor success at the time, and then it had a accumulation, a crude value, and then I remember like 10 years ago, a magazine from the UK, I think it was called Empire Magazine, And I remember like 10 years ago,
但我必须补充一点，杰森说，在《三个福星高照》成功之后，省略号……你其实是指在《三个福星高照》成功20年之后，省略号……它成功了吗？当时它只取得了小小的成功，然后它有了积累效应，增值了，然后我记得大约10年前，英国的一本杂志，我想它叫《帝国杂志》，然后我记得大约10年前，
a magazine from the UK, I think it was called Empire Magazine, they called it, we want to put you, Chevy and Marty on the cover. And I said, why? And they said, well, it's the 25th anniversary of Three Amigos. And it's a huge hit. You mean, somebody cares?
英国的一本杂志，我想它叫《帝国杂志》，他们打电话说，我们想把你、切维和马蒂放在封面。我说，为什么？他们说，嗯，这是《三个福星高照》上映25周年。这是一部巨大的热门作品。你的意思是，有人在乎？
I didn't think anybody even ever thought about it. Wow. Yeah, but the next year they did the cover of 25 years later from Ishtar. Yeah. So it's a magazine of flops. Yeah, I see now. Now, for a couple of fellas that usually
我以为从来没人想过这事呢。哇。是的，但第二年他们做了《伊斯塔尔》上映25周年的封面。所以这是一本专门做票房失利电影的杂志。是的，我明白了。现在，对于两个通常
with your level of success, wanna do, the last thing they wanna do is start bopping around the country on the frequency that you guys are, staying in hotels, going up live every night. Like, it's a big thing that you guys are doing all the time, to massive success, and you know, you could probably do a million more shows.
以你们的成功程度，最不想做的事就是开始像你们这样频繁地在全国各地巡演，住酒店，每天晚上登台演出。这就像是你们一直在做的一件大事，取得了巨大的成功，而且你知道的，你们可能还可以再做一百万场演出。
But when you put it that way, geez. But I mean, I just think it's just incredible that you guys are, is it getting, is it tiring? Are you sorry that you've got so much momentum built up with this and all the fans that you would disappoint if you stopped? I mean, you're screwed now. Well, the truth is, I enjoy working with Marty
但当你这么说的时候，天哪。但我的意思是，我只是觉得你们太不可思议了，这会让人感到疲惫吗？你会不会觉得，因为这个项目已经有了这么大的势头，如果停下来会让所有粉丝失望，你会为此感到遗憾吗？我的意思是，你们现在被套牢了。好吧，事实是，我很享受和马蒂一起工作，
and I think it's vice versa, so we actually enjoy it, and all that other stuff. You get yourself a nice sitcom, you know? You get six hours a day, and you're just down the street. Well, that's a good idea. No, you know, it seems like way more work than it is. It really is, because we'll do maybe four shows, and then we won't do it again for two weeks.
我想这也是互相的，所以我们其实很享受，以及所有其他那些事。你可以去拍个不错的情景喜剧，你知道的？每天工作六小时，离家又近。好吧，这是个好主意。不，你知道的，这看起来比实际工作要多得多。确实如此，因为我们可能连演四场，然后两周内都不会再演了。
Right, right. And they are fun, and then we, I mean, Steve and I will then, you know, have a glass of wine afterwards and discuss the show, and everyone kind of loves each other, because we have the Steep Canyon Rangers, and we have Jeff Babko, my piano guy, and everyone, and the stage manager,
对，对。而且它们很有趣，然后我们——我是说，史蒂夫和我随后会，你知道的，演出结束后喝一杯红酒，讨论一下演出，每个人都有点爱彼此，因为我们有史蒂夫峡谷游骑兵乐队，我们有杰夫·巴巴科，我的钢琴师，还有每个人，和舞台经理，
it's all become very close, so it's fun. Yeah. There are no pricks allowed. Our max is six, maybe seven shows a month. Okay. So it's not, you know, I couldn't do it because I got a family and I love being home. Yeah, me too.
大家都变得非常亲密，所以这很有趣。是的。这里不容许有讨厌鬼。我们的上限是每个月六场，也许七场演出。好吧。所以它不是，你知道的，我做不到，因为我有家庭，我喜欢呆在家里的感觉。是的，我也是。
Steve, is it true years and years ago, Steve, that you, I've always heard this, I've never had the fortunate opportunity to have one, but did you used to have cards made when people came up to you, asked for a photo or an autograph, and you would just hand them a card that said you've asked a pardon? I thought it was funny.
史蒂夫，多年前，史蒂夫，这是真的吗，我一直听说这个，我从来没有幸运的机会拥有一个，但是当有人走过来找你要照片或签名时，你以前是不是会制作卡片，然后直接递给他们一张写着“你已经被原谅了”的卡片？我觉得这挺搞笑的。
This is in the 70s when I was getting asked for a lot of autographs. And so I made up a card, and it said, because I thought, what do people really want when they get an autograph? They want to say that they met you, that's the main thing, and what was he like? In the 12 seconds that they met you, what was he like? So I wrote, this certifies that you met me
这大概是70年代的时候，当时我经常被索要签名。于是我制作了一张卡片，上面写着，因为我想，人们在索要签名时真正想要的是什么？他们想说他们见到了你，这才是最重要的，而他是个什么样的人？在与你相遇的这12秒里，他是个怎样的人？所以我写道：兹证明你见到了我
and found me warm, charming, intelligent, and funny, and then I had a printed signature on it, then I found I'd give the cards out, thinking it was hilarious, and then they'd say, could you sign this? No way. Yeah, so I said, well, that's over. Oh, wow.
并且发现我又热情、又有魅力、聪明又风趣，然后上面印着我的签名。后来我发现，我把这些卡片发出去时觉得太搞笑了，结果他们会说：“你能签个名吗？”没门。是啊，所以我说，这招行不通了。噢，天哪。
When you guys come together and you think up another show, because how many of the live tours have you guys done? It's four, five, six? Well, you mean different titles. I mean, but we keep changing the material all the time. We always. Well, in fairness, it's slowly evolving. We never throw everything out
当你们聚在一起构思另一档节目的时候，因为你们做过多少次现场巡演了？四次、五次、六次？哦，我是说不同的主题。我是说，但我们一直在不断改变内容。我们总是……好吧平心而论，它是在慢慢演变的。我们从来不会把所有东西都抛弃
and then bring everything new in. It would be impossible. So it just slowly evolves. Yeah, like what is that process like? Would it be like what the process would be, I'm assuming for standup, where you've got to spend a bunch of weeks or months accruing brand new material, observations, jokes, et cetera,
然后带来全新的内容。那是不可能的。所以它只是在慢慢演变。对啊，那个过程是怎样的？是不是就像我猜想的单口喜剧的过程一样，你得花好几周或几个月的时间来积累全新的段子、观察、笑话等等，
and shape that into a set that you like. Is that the same process you guys go through or no? You're saying it's sort of the same core and then you just kind of update it, yeah? Yeah, we change things one line at a time. And then every once in a while we'll come up with a new idea and we'll put it in whole. And is there a formal process when you guys
然后把它们塑造成你喜欢的演出环节。你们经历的也是这个过程吗？还是说不是？你是说核心内容差不多，然后只是做一些更新，是吗？对，我们一行行地修改内容。然后偶尔会蹦出一个新点子，然后整个加进去。那你们有没有一个正式的过程，比方说
will get together and write? And will you do it via zoom? Will you just sit there zoom? We'll do zoom Yeah, we'll do zoom and we'll have a bunch of material in front of us and we'll but but you know We'll do that at the beginning of a tour if we have a lot of new material to go over Would you guys consider doing like Google spaces or Microsoft teams? We don't want to fuck with your process, your creative process, I'm just saying.
聚在一起写东西？你们会通过Zoom吗？就坐在那里用Zoom？我们会用Zoom，对，我们会用Zoom，面前放着一堆素材，我们会……不过你知道的，在巡演刚开始时，如果我们有很多新素材要过一遍，就会这样做。你们会考虑用Google Spaces或Microsoft Teams吗？我们可不想干扰你们的流程，你们的创作流程，我只是随便说说。
Now, Marty, is it true, Marty, that you originally saw yourself more as a singer and an actor? And if so, at what point did you feel it was a safe pivot to go into straight up comedy, screw the singing, screw the, I'm not gonna be a character. And do you regret it? And do you?
马蒂，这是真的吗？马蒂，你最初觉得自己更像是一个歌手和演员？如果是这样，你是在什么时候觉得可以安全转型去演纯喜剧，别管唱歌了，别管别的了，我不打算演什么角色了？你后悔吗？你后悔过吗？
And what were you thinking? No, I think it wasn't until I joined Second City in Toronto that I started to develop characters and realized that I could improvise and all that stuff. But up until then I thought I wanted to be Sinatra. Frank Jr. oddly enough, not the father. And I wanted to. And I used to, you know, I used to do musicals
你当时是怎么想的？不，我觉得直到我加入多伦多的“第二城”（Second City）剧团后，我才开始塑造角色，并意识到自己可以进行即兴表演诸如此类的。但在那之前，我以为我想成为弗兰克·辛纳屈。说来也怪，是小弗兰克，而不是他父亲。我想……我以前，你知道的，我以前演过音乐剧
and I would do plays. But I'm sure you must have been, you must have had some comedic success in high school, right, junior high? Well, no, no, I was funny in the class. I heard you killed in St. Catharines. I heard that you would kill in Hamilton and say Catherine Oh, yeah, you know at the hungry hungry lion and
我还会演话剧。但我敢肯定你以前一定，你在高中或者初中时一定取得过一些喜剧方面的成功，对吧？嗯，没有，没有，我在班上挺搞笑的。我听说你在圣凯瑟琳很受欢迎。我听说你在汉密尔顿和圣凯瑟琳一出场就能把全场逗翻。哦，对，你知道的，在“饥饿的狮子”餐厅还有……
No, I I was I grew up in a very funny family My brother Michael has won many Emmys and awards from writing everything from SC TV to Schitt's Creek But so he was the eldest and it was very funny family. My father was funny. So it was kind of natural to be funny, but I never thought of it as something I would do until later on. And as you know, Marty is an incredible singer. I mean, I listen to him on stage every night.
不，我……我是在一个非常搞笑的家庭长大的。我哥哥迈克尔获得过很多艾美奖和各种奖项，他写过从《SCTV》到《富家穷路》的各种剧本。但他排行老大，我们家真的很搞笑。我父亲就很幽默。所以搞笑可以说是天生的，但我从来没想过把它当成我以后会从事的事业，直到后来。而且如你所知，马蒂是个了不起的歌手。我的意思是，我每天晚上在舞台上听他唱歌。
He's never flat, he's never sharp, and curiously, he's never on the note. But. But no, he's incredible. He never misses, he has a beautiful tone. Is he a better singer than you are a banjo player? Absolutely. Is he?
他从不走音，从不升调，而且奇怪的是，他从来就没在调上。但是……不过说真的，他很厉害。他从不出错，音色非常优美。他唱歌比你弹斑鸠琴更好听吗？绝对的。是吗？
That's high praise, because you know what you're doing on that thing, right? Well, oh Steve's good. I do in a way. There could be some Grammys there. In fact, whenever Steve plays the banjo. I've won Grammys playing the banjo. You've won many Grammys, Steve, haven't you?
这可是极高的评价，因为你对那玩意儿也很在行，对吧？呃，奥，史蒂夫挺厉害的。从某种程度上说，是的。那里面可能藏着好几个格莱美奖呢。事实上，每当史蒂夫弹斑鸠琴时……我弹斑鸠琴拿过格莱美奖。史蒂夫，你拿过很多格莱美奖，对吧？
Playing the banjo, hell yeah. Whenever Steve plays the banjo, I like to just close my eyes and pretend I'm on hold with Cracker Barrel. Pfft. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha We do some songs, but we use piano and we use our orchestra, but we don't have a banjo number. Jason, have you not seen it? No, I've never been invited. It's so good, it's so funny and so, it's hysterical. What, the show?
弹斑鸠琴，那当然！每当史蒂夫弹斑鸠琴时，我都喜欢闭上眼睛，假装自己正挂着电话在听Cracker Barrel餐厅的客服语音。噗！哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
I've never, I haven't seen it either. I've been busy. I've been, in my defense, I'm very busy. Yeah, I know, you've mentioned, I hear, I listen to Smartless all the time, and I always hear, you've said many times, I'm busy. I'm very busy, yeah. I'm just not sure at what. Yeah. I'm busy. I'm very busy. Yes, not sure at what yeah
我也没看，我还没看过呢。我一直挺忙的。为了自辩一下，我真的很忙。对，我懂，你提过，我听过，我经常听Smartless播客，我总听到你多次说过：我很忙。我很忙，对。只是我不确定你在忙什么。对。我很忙。我很忙。是的，只是不确定在忙什么，对。
What country wait wait Steve? I want to ask you actually you mentioned Grammys And you've won Grammys for your banjo playing, but you've also won many Grammys for stand-up over the years and I Do you I don't know if you do any stand-up anymore at all, ever? The only stand-up I do is in our show. Yeah. I call it stand-up with Marty, but we each have a section in our show, and I just sort of do monologue jokes
什么国家，等等，等等，史蒂夫？其实我想问你，你提到了格莱美，你因为弹斑鸠琴赢得过格莱美，但这些年来你也因为单口喜剧赢得过许多格莱美，你还会——我不知道你是否还偶尔做点单口喜剧？我唯一的单口喜剧就是在我们的演出里。对。我把它叫作“与马蒂一起的单口喜剧”，不过我们在演出里各有一个环节，我基本上就是讲讲独白笑话，
and introduce the song on the banjo and play it. But I love doing it. It took me as long, as much time to work out that 10 minutes as it used to take to work out 10 minutes. You realize you're three years into this and you've got one little area that's weak and you're trying to fix it.
然后引出斑鸠琴的弹唱。但我很喜欢这么做。我花在打磨那十分钟上的时间，和以前花时间打磨十分钟节目一样长。你意识到你已经搞了三年了，结果发现还有一个小地方有点弱，然后你一直在试图修复它。
And now it's feeling really good now that it's old and overexposed. Is there, what is the oldest joke that you still include in your set? Like the one that just never fails, it goes all the way back to Carson perhaps, appearances there, no, anything? I don't, I don't.
现在它终于感觉真的很不错了，既然它已经变得既老套又过度曝光了。有没有——你现在仍在演出中保留的哪个笑话是最老的？比如那种百试不灵的笑话，可能一直追溯到卡森时代，你在那里的露面什么的，没有吗？没有，没有。
I mean there's jokes that, for example, when we did our Netflix special, then we really started trying to change things out. And then three years later, we're talking, we're going, you know what, I missed that one joke, blah, blah, blah. And then we would put it back in, and then no one knew or cared. Marty, you're famous for really loving preparing
我是说有些笑话，比如说，当我们做了我们的网飞（Netflix）特辑之后，我们才真正开始尝试换掉一些内容。然后三年后，我们在聊天时说，你知道吗，我有点想念那个笑话了，云云。然后我们会把它加回去，结果根本没人知道，也没人在乎。马蒂，你以非常热爱为
very deeply for talk show appearances. I thought you were gonna say, Marty, you're famous for using the same old joke. Which one is your favorite? Which one of the three? How is it to deeply prepare using old material? But you enjoy, did I hear this right, that you enjoy preparing for talk show appearances? Or is some of us... Well, I just have a philosophy about it.
脱口秀节目的出场做极其充分的准备而闻名。我还以为你会说：“马蒂，你以总是用老笑话而闻名。”你最喜欢哪一个？这三个里你最喜欢哪个？用老旧的素材做深度准备是什么体验？不过你很享受——我没听错吧，你很享受为脱口秀节目做准备？还是说我们当中有些人……嗯，我对此有自己的一套哲学。
I mean, I just kind of... It's like... It's work and you've got to prepare. I just don't want to go out and fail and feel it was my fault. So if I send in, you know, 15 pages and then I go out with Kimmel or Letterman or Fallon or whoever and they're off or I'm a little off. But if I go out gunning for bear,
我的意思是，我差不多就是……这就像是一份工作，你必须做好准备。我可不想表现拉胯然后觉得是自己的错。所以如果我交出了，你知道的，15页的稿子，然后我去上吉米（Kimmel）、莱特曼（Letterman）、法伦（Fallon）或者其他谁的节目，结果他们状态不佳，或者我稍微有点不在状态。但如果我全力以赴、志在必得，
I feel like whatever happens, I can still toast myself because I did everything I could do. I feel the exact same way. How's it going today for you? Did you prepare today? I did and none of it is working. You know? You should toast yourself because you did your best. You should toast yourself, because you did your best.
我觉得无论发生什么，我至少还能为自己举杯庆祝，因为我已经尽我所能了。我完全有同感。你今天感觉怎么样？你今天做准备了吗？我准备了，但一点用也没有。你知道吗？你应该为自己举杯庆祝，因为你已经尽力了。你应该为自己举杯庆祝，因为你尽力了。
You should toast yourself. You know what I should? I should. I mean, I got the lighting. Again, to sort of the portion of the interview, hashtag relatable, talking about talk show appearances, I find that I get, I start to feel sad, and like I'm losing my soul,
你应该为自己举杯庆祝。你知道我该不该吗？我应该。我是说，我把灯光都弄好了。再次回到采访的那个部分——话题标签“引起共鸣”，谈到上脱口秀节目的经历，我发现我开始感到难过，感觉自己正在失去灵魂，
as I start to like, the two weeks before the talk show appearance, I start to really try to log things in my life. Oh, this would be good to talk about. Or this would be good. And they're like deeply personal, cute moments like with your children or whatever. And you think, well, fuck, why am I logging this
就在我开始——在上脱口秀节目前两周，我开始真正试着把生活中的事情记录下来。哦，这个聊起来一定不错。或者这个挺好。而且它们都是极其私人的、温馨的时刻，比如和你的孩子在一起的经历什么的。然后你会想，好吧，操，我为什么要为了一个脱口秀节目来记录这些
for a talk show? I should be. Yeah, but it all works out, Jason. I should save this for a movie. I should save it for a TV show. No, no, but it works out because, no really, you're working, you're working, you're feeling, you're losing your soul,
我应该……对，但一切都会迎刃而解的，杰森。我应该把这留给电影。我应该把这留给电视剧。不，不，但结果会很好的，因为，说真的，你在工作，你在感受，你在失去灵魂，
you feel sad and depressed, and then when you do it, that's what the audience feels. So it's a journey. It's a journey. You transferred to the audience. Yes. I'm not sure what you mean. You mean you feel like you're giving away
你感到悲伤和沮丧，然后当你真的把它说出来时，这就是观众所感受到的。所以这是一个历程。这是一个历程。你把它传递给了观众。是的。我不太明白你的意思。你是说你觉得你是在为了
your private life to do a talk show anecdote? No mean you feel like you're giving away your private life to do a talk show anecdote? No, I feel like I should be more present in my moment with my children or whatever instead of thinking, oh, this is funny what she's doing. I'm gonna talk to Kimmel about this. Like that's just like. No, you're doing the right thing.
在脱口秀上讲个轶事而放弃你的私生活吗？不，你是说你觉得你为了在脱口秀上讲个轶事而放弃了私生活？不，我只是觉得我应该更多地活在当下，陪着我的孩子或别的什么，而不是脑子里想着：“哦，她刚才这个举止挺好笑的，我要去跟吉米聊聊这个。”就好像这纯粹是……不，你做得对。
You're doing the right thing. Use them on that. It's interesting, Marty, we've talked about this before where people don't realize those kinds of on-camera interviews on those talk shows are kind of performances, and it's like we've all seen them and all witnessed them, so we know what the good ones look like. Every single person in show business.
你做得对。在那个节目里用它们吧。有趣的是，马蒂，我们以前讨论过这个，人们没有意识到在那些脱口秀节目中的那种面对面采访其实是一种表演，就像我们都看过、也都见证过的那样，所以我们知道好的采访是什么样的。演艺圈里的每一个人都清楚。
So don't you wanna do a good one? The first talk show I ever did was in 1982 on Letterman, and I kept thinking, what do I, like same thing you're saying, Jason, what do I talk about, what do I, like same thing you're saying, Jason, what do I talk about, what do I think about? And then I realized, oh, I get it. It's like being at a dinner party where everyone's had some drinks
所以难道你不想表现好一点吗？我上的第一个脱口秀是1982年在莱特曼的节目上，我当时一直在想，我该说些什么？就像你刚才说的一样，杰森，我该说些什么，我该想些什么？然后我意识到，哦，我明白了。这就像是在一个晚宴上，每个人都喝了点酒，
and you're kind of on and telling stories, but somehow you have to lift that six minutes because you don't have the hour and a half ramp. Or the booze. Yeah, you know what I can't stand though is when people go on who are funny, like considered funny people in the business, and they just like to talk about something serious,
你处于亢奋状态并在讲故事，但不知何故，你必须把那六分钟的内容撑起来，因为你没有一个半小时的铺垫时间。也没有酒。是啊，你知道我最受不了的是什么吗？当一些有趣的人上节目时——也就是业内公认有趣的人，他们偏要谈论一些严肃的话题，
and people at home are judging them, and they go, oh I saw them on Letterman, or Fallon, or whatever, or Kimmel. They're not that funny. They're not that funny. Yet, yet, a dramatic actor goes on, and says one funny thing. People at home go, and they can do comedy.
坐在电视机前的观众就会对他们评头论足，然后他们会说：“哦，我在莱特曼、法伦、别的什么节目或吉米那里看到过他们。他们其实没那么搞笑。他们没那么搞笑。”然而，然而，一个正剧演员上节目，讲了一个好笑的笑话，电视机前的人就会说：“天哪，他也能搞笑。”
It's amazing. Yeah. You know? I used to really resent having to. We're so bitter. Yeah, I know. And funny thing, people at home go, and they can do comedy, it's amazing. You know? I used to really resent having to. We're so bitter. Yeah. I know. I used, when I was young and dumb and really super duper full of myself, I used to think, oh, you know,
这太神奇了。你知道吗？我以前真的很怨恨不得不……我们太刻薄了。是啊，我懂。而且有趣的是，电视机前的人会说：“天哪，他也能搞笑，这太神奇了。”你知道吗？我以前真的很怨恨不得不……我们太刻薄了。是啊。我懂。我以前，当我年轻、愚蠢且极度自以为是的时候，我曾想过：“哦，你知道的，
I'm going on this talk show, like, they're lucky to have me, I don't have to prepare anything, fuck that, you know, and they're not paying me to write. And of course, you know, the appearances were terrible. And I would see them and I was just like, oh my God, you punk. And then as I got older and wiser, as we all do, then you start really working on stuff.
我要上这个脱口秀了，他们能请到我是他们的福气，我才不需要准备什么呢，去他的吧，”你知道的，“他们又没付我写稿的钱。”当然了，结果可想而知，那些节目表现得一塌糊涂。当我回看那些节目时，我只会想：“哦天哪，你这个混蛋。”然后随着我年龄渐长、阅历渐丰，正如我们所有人一样，你才开始真正用心去准备各种内容。
And that pre-interview with the producer for Tracy, a lot of this stuff is talked about beforehand so that there is a cohesive six minutes where you're gonna get to a few questions. And not that the answers are prepared, but you've got sort of an angle that might be entertaining for the audience. But all the hosts vary.
而且跟特西（Tracy）的制片人进行的那次赛前采访，很多事情都是提前沟通好的，这样才能呈现出一个连贯的六分钟，让你有机会回答几个问题。倒不是说答案是提前背好的，而是你已经找到了一种可能对观众来说很有趣的切入点。不过所有主持人的风格都不尽相同。
I mean, you know, sometimes you go. But when I would do Letterman, I swear he would hit one quarter of what I'd prepared. One time he said, tell the Tony Randall story. And I said, I was on two months ago and told the Tony Randall story, Dave. He said, I don't care, tell it again. I have a secret fantasy, which is to go on a talk show,
我是说，你知道的，有时候你去……但当我上莱特曼的节目时，我发誓他只会用到我准备内容的四分之一。有一次他说：“讲讲托尼·兰德尔（Tony Randall）的那个故事吧。”我说：“我两个月前刚上过节目，已经讲过托尼·兰德尔的故事了，戴夫。”他说：“我不在乎，再讲一遍。”我有一个秘密幻想，就是去上一档脱口秀节目，
totally unprepared, and just to see what happens. But you could do that and you could do that and there are certain hosts that could definitely do that and not need that, because sometimes the notes are really almost there more for them. But a lot of them, like Kimmel for instance, you can just go on there
完全不做准备，就看看会发生什么。但你可以做到这一点，你完全可以做到，而且确实有某些主持人绝对能做到这一点，不需要这些准备，因为有时候准备提示卡其实更多是为了他们自己。但很多主持人，比如吉米，你直接上节目就行了，
and you can just go right off the questions. You sit down, how you doing? Great, and you guys are just both riffing. You're having a conversation like we're having. I mean, we're barely prepared, I'm certainly barely prepared. What's my next question here? I don't know.
你可以完全脱离问题。你坐下来，“最近怎么样？”“太棒了，”然后你们两个就开始互抛梗。你们就像我们在这样聊天。我是说，我们几乎没做准备，我当然也几乎没做准备。我接下来的问题是什么？我不知道。
I wanna talk about only murders. Did you guys, first of all, we share a mutual friend, John Hoffman, who I love. Yes. The bright, he's always cheery, always sweet, always kind. Would kill the head half of the- And then he stabs you in the back. Yeah. Did you guys know when you in the back. Yeah.
我想聊聊《大楼里只有谋杀》。你们……首先，我们有一个共同的朋友，约翰·霍夫曼（John Hoffman），我太喜欢他了。是的。他很聪明，总是高高兴兴的，总是很甜蜜，总是很善良。恨不得把前半部分的……然后他就在背后捅你一刀。对。你们在……背后捅你一刀。对。
Did you guys know when you were developing it together, not of, I hate that question, did you know it was gonna work, but did you have a sense that with the writing and you guys and like the first table reads and the first kind of days of shooting, like yeah, this is, we have something here, or were you still kind of unsure
你们在共同开发这部剧的时候——我讨厌那个问题：“你们知道它会成功吗？”——但你们当时有没有一种感觉，凭着剧本、你们几个人的合作，以及第一次围读剧本和最初的几天拍摄，觉得“没错，我们这次真的搞出点名堂了”？还是说你们其实心里还是有点没底，
until the season was wrapped? Didn't know a thing, Didn't know a thing. You just write it according to the premise. And then when it started to hit the air, and you started to get back word that, why the way, it's the biggest debut that ever, and that sort of thing. I don't know how accurate that is.
直到整季杀青才确定？一点也不知道，一点也不知道。你只是根据设定来写剧本。然后当它开始播出，你开始收到反馈说，顺便一提，这是史上收视成绩最好的首播集，诸如此类。我不知道这准确度有多高。
Yeah, it's huge. And that's when you start to get excited, but you don't change anything because of that. You just, oh. And then even a year and a half later, you start to go, what is this? Yeah, right. Yeah.
对，它反响巨大。然后你才开始兴奋起来，但你不会因此改变任何东西。你只是，哦。甚至在一年半之后，你还会开始想：这到底是个啥？是啊，对。对。
We'll be right back. We get support from Happy Egg, and here's the deal. I love starting my morning off with farm fresh eggs that are just packed with flavor. At Happy Egg, all of their hens roam on eight or more acres of land, leaving no mystery as to why their eggs are the best. They are cared for by these small family farmers, and they live their best hen lives day in and day out. Aside from the hens roaming across eight plus acres of farmland, you heard me
我们马上回来。我们得到了Happy Egg的赞助，事情是这样的。我喜欢以农场新鲜的鸡蛋开启我的早晨，它们真的充满了风味。在Happy Egg，所有的母鸡都在八英亩或更多的土地上自由放养，这毫无悬念地解释了为什么它们的鸡蛋是最好的。它们由这些小家庭农场的农民精心照料，日复一日地过着它们最好的母鸡生活。除了母鸡在八英亩以上的农田里自由漫步，你没听错，
correctly, they have plenty of access to fresh water and nutritious feed and this goes above the traditional free-range farming. But it's what they believe is better for their birds overall and all of this results in eggs with plump orange yolks that are full of flavor. I like a Western omelet. OK, I'm going full disclosure. I like it. I like it with the peppers and the ham and the cheese.
它们有充足的渠道获取清水和营养丰富的饲料，这超出了传统的散养模式。但这正是他们认为对鸟类整体更好的方式，所有这一切最终转化为蛋黄饱满、呈橙色且充满风味的鸡蛋。我喜欢西部煎蛋卷。好吧，我坦白。我喜欢它。我喜欢里面有辣椒、火腿和奶酪的。
But what I like to start with, the pillar of this Western omelet, is a happy egg with a plump orange yolk. So next time you're at the store, look for the yellow carton. Choose happy with happy egg. Visit happyegg.com slash smartless to find a store near you. Smartless is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app.
但我最想开始的，这个西部煎蛋卷的基石，就是一个有着饱满橙色蛋黄的Happy Egg鸡蛋。所以下次你去商店时，认准黄色纸盒。选择Happy Egg，选择快乐。访问happyegg.com/smartless寻找离你最近的商店。Smartless由Audible部分赞助播出。Audible让你在一个应用中享受所有音频娱乐。
You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs or mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, everything. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases.
你总能找到你最爱的最佳内容或发现全新的东西。他们提供横跨各个流派的令人难以置信的有声书选择，从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑惊悚片、励志、健康、商业，应有尽有。Audible是您体验惊心动魄的音频娱乐的目的地，这里有备受期待的新发售作品以及为每一位惊悚片听众量身定制的“下一本收听”推荐。作为Audible会员，您可以每月从整个目录中选择一本图书永久保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。
For me, it's The Anxious Generation by Jonathan Haidt. It is my new audible book I'm onto. And it's narrated by Sean Pratt and Jonathan Haidt, which is amazing. And it's just one of those books that is just really striking a chord. And listening to them narrated is a great way to do it. And, you know, it's obviously talking about the impact of phones on this young generation as a parent, it's pretty striking. So I encourage you to listen to The Anxious Generation or any of your book favorites over on Audible. And new members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless
对我来说，是乔纳森·海特（Jonathan Haidt）的《焦虑的一代》（The Anxious Generation）。这是我正在听的新Audible有声书。它由肖恩·普拉特（Sean Pratt）和乔纳森·海特本人旁白，这太棒了。它就是那种真正能引起强烈共鸣的书之一。听他们旁白真的是一种很棒的体验。而且，你知道的，它显然作为父母探讨了手机对年轻一代的影响，这相当震撼。所以我鼓励你在Audible上收听《焦虑的一代》或你喜爱的任何书籍。新会员可以免费体验Audible 30天。访问audible.com/smartless
or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartless. future finance offering stock trading, IRAs, and many more products to over 26 million funded accounts. With Robinhood, it's simple to make investments towards your future goals, whatever those may be. Maybe you wanna work towards investing
或者发送短信“smartless”到500-500。网址是audible.com/smartless，或者发送短信“smartless”到500-500即可免费试用Audible 30天。audible.com/smartless。未来金融服务为超过2600万个有资金注入的账户提供股票交易、IRA以及更多产品。有了Robinhood，为你的未来目标进行投资变得很简单，无论这些目标是什么。也许你想要为
for your family's future, a vacation this summer, or visiting, I don't know, every baseball stadium in the country. We all have some bucket list items to cross off, and Robinhood has tools that can help you pursue them. You know, it's pretty cool to have the power of investing and trading on your phone in the palm of your hand. You can be anywhere in the world and use Robinhood has tools that can help you pursue them. You know, it's pretty cool to have the power of investing and trading on your phone in the palm of your hand. You can be anywhere in the world and use Robinhood.
你家人的未来、今年夏天的假期进行投资，或者去参观——我不知道，全国的每一座棒球场。我们都有一些愿望清单上的事项要去勾选，而Robinhood拥有可以帮助你实现这些目标的工具。你知道的，把投资和交易的力量掌握在手机里，握在手心，这真的很酷。你可以身处世界的任何地方，并使用……Robinhood拥有可以帮助你实现这些目标的工具。你知道的，把投资和交易的力量掌握在手机里，握在手心，这真的很酷。你可以身处世界的任何地方，并使用Robinhood。
It sounds really, really cool. Take your financial future by the reins, download the app or visit Robinhood.com to learn more. Investing involves risk and loss of principal is possible. Returns are not guaranteed. Robinhood Financial LLC member, SIPC, is a registered broker dealer. We get support from State Farm. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there.
听起来真的非常非常酷。把你的财务未来掌握在自己手中，下载应用程序或访问Robinhood.com了解更多信息。投资涉及风险，本金可能亏损。回报不保证。Robinhood Financial LLC成员，SIPC，是一家注册经纪交易商。我们得到了State Farm的支持。像个好邻居，State Farm就在身边。
When you hear those words, you can feel good knowing that State Farm is there to help you feel supported with the coverage you need for your car, your home, and even boats, motorcycles, RVs, and other things that matter to you. When things get complicated and you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. Maybe you like to handle things in person or on the phone with your local agent, or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com
当你听到这些话时，你会感到安心，因为你知道State Farm会在那里帮助你获得所需的保障，涵盖你的汽车、你的家，甚至船只、摩托车、房车以及对你重要的其他事情。当事情变得复杂，你需要寻求帮助的途径时，State Farm也为你提供了多种选择。也许你喜欢亲自或通过电话与当地的代理人沟通，或者你更喜欢在statefarm.com上操作，
or on their award-winning app. State Farm lets you do things your way. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. And back to the show. And back to the show. Now, there's word that you guys are going to be going to Los Angeles with it. Is the whole show switching to Los Angeles or no? Well, that's one of those news stories
或者在他们屡获殊荣的应用程序上操作。State Farm让你以自己的方式处理事情。像个好邻居，State Farm就在身边。让我们回到节目中来。让我们回到节目中来。现在有消息说你们要带着这部剧去洛杉矶了。整部剧是要转场到洛杉矶了吗，还是说没有？嗯，那完全是那种新闻报道的误传，
because we're shooting two days in Los Angeles that it's mistaken for, they're moving to the entire season, you know. No, it's just, it's like a location shoot. Oh, gotcha, but it is shot in New York. Right. Yes. Do you both live in New York? Steve lives in New York.
因为我们要在洛杉矶拍摄两天，结果就被误会成“他们要搬去拍整整一季了”。不是的，它只是一次外景拍摄。哦，明白了，但它确实是在纽约拍摄的。对的。是的。你们俩都住在纽约吗？史蒂夫住在纽约。
I rent in New York. But you rent while we're shooting. You don't live in New York. That is correct, sir. Would you guys like for it to be shot in Los Angeles 100% of the time? That was my, you know, when I had the idea for the show, I pitched it to them, to the producers, Dan Fogelman
我在纽约租房。但你是在我们拍戏的时候租房。你并不住在纽约。完全正确，先生。你们希望这部剧百分之百在洛杉矶拍摄吗？那就是我——你知道的，当我有了这个节目的构思时，我把它推销给他们，也就是制片人丹·福格尔曼（Dan Fogelman）
and Jess Rosenthal, based on, I wasn't even in it. I said, I think this is a good idea, and we liked it. Then they called me and said, would you do it? And I said, well, I can't. I could only do it if it's shot in New York. And then that's what, that's why it was shot. And also it's a New York show, which makes it kind of great. That's the thing, it's great that it's shot in New York.
和杰斯·罗森塔尔（Jess Rosenthal），当时甚至都没打算我自己演。我说：“我觉得这是个好主意，”然后他们也挺喜欢。接着他们打电话给我说：“你来演吗？”我说：“哦，我演不了。只有在纽约拍我才演。”然后就是这样，这也是为什么它会在纽约拍摄。而且它本身就是一部纽约风格的剧，这让它变得非常棒。就是这样，能在纽约拍摄真的很棒。
It feels 100% like a New York show. And you just added Molly Shannon, I read. Molly Shannon, yes. That's super fun. You have a great cast of people on that show. So fantastic. And that's what, when we get somebody that we can, like, we worked with Matthew Broderick, it was like so easy and the comedy is so good.
它感觉百分之百是一部纽约的剧。而且我读到你们还加入了莫莉·香农（Molly Shannon）。莫莉·香农，是的。这太有趣了。你们在这部剧里有一支出色的演员阵容。棒极了。这就是——当我们遇到能够合作的演员时，比如我们和马修·布罗德里克（Matthew Broderick）合作过，感觉非常轻松，喜剧效果也很好。
It's like you've worked together all, you know, your whole lives. Yeah, Matthew's great, I love him. But talk about an out of the box piece of casting with Selena Gomez just obviously seems incredibly genius now, but like, the two of you with her is so unexpected. How did that come about? It came about after the fact, because I had originally pitched it as three older people who have a lot of time on their hands.
就像你们已经合作了……你知道的，一辈子的那种。对，马修很棒，我很喜欢他。但说到一个意料之外的选角，塞琳娜·戈麦斯（Selena Gomez）显然现在看来极其天才，但你们两个和她合作是如此出乎意料。这是怎么促成的？这是事后才促成的，因为我最初把它构思为三个有很多闲暇时光的老年人。
And, you know. We were busy. And then I think the studio suggested, what about Selena actually? What about Selena? And we met her on Zoom and she, they actually cast her and we met her on Zoom and Marty and I, after the Zoom, we called each other
而且，你知道的。我们很忙。然后我觉得工作室提议：“塞琳娜怎么样？”“塞琳娜怎么样？”我们在Zoom上见到了她，她——他们实际上选定了她，我们在Zoom上见到了她，然后马蒂和我，在Zoom结束后互相打电话说，
and go, she's perfect. Yeah, wow. She's so sweet. Well I still wasn't sure, I was saying, maybe a female but what about Kathy Lee Gifford? She's a little higher but a champion of you you pull out names from from an old hat From the Harry Potter sorting yeah now Talk about another thing that you would think would be unexpected, because Steve,
“她太完美了。”对，哇。她太甜了。好吧，我当时还是不太确定，我说：“也许是个女演员，但凯茜·李·吉福德（Kathy Lee Gifford）怎么样？”她稍微高一点，但你是从一个旧帽子里抽出了这些名字。从哈利·波特的分配帽里，对。现在，说到另一件你觉得会很出乎意料的事，因为史蒂夫，
you've lived a very private life. It's very, very cool, very mysterious. I love that about you. You don't seek attention, Marty. And yet you've got this, but there's this documentary coming out that is covering you from soup to nuts, or already out. And was that pulling teeth to get you to be a participant?
你一直过着非常私密的生活。非常非常酷，非常神秘。我特别喜欢你这一点。你并不寻求关注，马蒂。然而你却有这个——但现在有一部纪录片要出了，从头到尾记录了你的一生，或者说已经上映了。让你参与拍摄是不是像拔牙一样难？
I mean, Morgan Neville as a director would probably a huge draw for you, but. Yes, Morgan Neville. I'm so glad. What's it called? It's called Steve! Okay, yeah, Steve! And I got a call from Morgan Neville about this documentary
我是说，摩根·内维尔（Morgan Neville）作为导演对你来说可能是个巨大的吸引力，但是……是的，摩根·内维尔。我太高兴了。它叫什么名字？它叫《Steve！》。好吧，对，《Steve！》。我接到了摩根·内维尔关于这部纪录片的电话，
and his credits are, Won't You Be My Neighbor and 20 Feet From Stardom. So many, he did a thing called Cool School. And I met him, we got along, and when you do a documentary you have to open up, first of all your archives, which I happen to have, they told me, he said, you have a lot of archives. And I didn't realize I had a lot of archives.
他的代表作有《与我为邻》（Won't You Be My Neighbor）和《离巨星只有二十英尺》（20 Feet From Stardom）。还有很多，他还拍过一个叫《酷学校》（Cool School）的东西。我见了他，我们相处得很融洽，当你拍纪录片时，你必须敞开心扉，首先要打开你的档案库，而我刚好有档案库，他们告诉我，他说：“你有很多档案。”而我以前根本没意识到自己有那么多档案。
So they went, prowled through my archives for months and months and months and found things that they found. Like an old sock? A photo. Pardon me. A photo of an old sock. He kept the photo, not the sock. I love too that you didn't know you had archives.
于是他们去翻找，在我的档案库里搜寻了几个月又几个月，找到了他们觉得有意思的东西。比如一只旧袜子？一张照片。对不起。一张旧袜子的照片。他留下了照片，没留袜子。我也很喜欢你居然不知道自己有档案库。
You were just like, who was saving them then? It was a cherished sock. Anyway, they found a photo of my father in Germany in 1943 Three doing a USO show. Oh, thank God Wait Steve Steve, let me ask you, did you start archiving years ago, hire one of these people to do that?
你当时就觉得：“那当年是谁在存这些东西啊？”那可是一只珍贵的袜子。不管怎样，他们在1943年的德国找到了一张我父亲的照片，当时他正在进行劳军联合演出（USO show）。哦，谢天谢地！等等，史蒂夫，史蒂夫，让我问你，你很多年前就开始存档了吗，还是雇了什么人来做这事？
I did not archive, I saved things. And I realized later, I would take things like, oh I'm on a magazine cover, I'll save it and I'd throw it in a thing. I was saving all the wrong stuff. I should have saved photos, which you know, photos were hard to come by then. You just didn't snap it. You had the photo that was sent in.
我没有专门存档，我只是把东西留了下来。后来我意识到，我会拿一些东西，比如“哦，我上了杂志封面，我把它留下来”，然后随手扔进一个盒子里。我当时留下的全都是错的东西。我应该留照片的，你知道的，那会儿照片很难弄到。你不能随手就拍一张。你只有别人寄过来的照片。
And the thing is, you know, change film, the whole thing. So, but when I wrote my autobiography, I did have one little plastic box where I just threw things in. And that had things like a receipt from a hotel in Salt Lake City in 1971. So you knew where you were at that date and you could research.
而且问题是，你知道的，换胶卷，整个过程都很麻烦。所以，但当我写自传时，我的确有一个小塑料盒，我把东西随手扔在里面。里面有些东西，比如一张1971年在盐湖城一家酒店的收据。所以你能知道自己在那个日期的确切位置，然后你就可以进行考证。
Do you remember her name though? It was like archeological because as it went down, you would go past time, go through time. It was like archeological because as it went down, you would go past time, go through time. I went to, speaking about receipts, I went to, when Marty's biography came out, he didn't send me one, so I went to the bookstore, bought it, and while I was at the cash register, put the book and the receipt, took a photo of it,
不过你还记得她的名字吗？这简直就像是考古，因为随着它越堆越深，你会穿越时光，经历时间。这就好像考古一样，因为随着它越堆越深，你会穿越时光，经历时间。我去过——说到收据，我去过——当马蒂的自传出版时，他没给我寄一本，所以我去书店买了一本，当我在收银台时，把书和收据放在一起，拍了张照片，
emailed him and said, that's okay, I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it.
发电子邮件给他，说：“没关系，我拿到了。”我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。
I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it.
我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。
I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. you needed it, it's there. It's got plenty. Marty, what about a documentary biography for you? Like a documentary.
我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。我拿到了。当你需要它时，它就在那儿。里面东西多得很。马蒂，为你拍一部纪录片传记怎么样？就像一部纪录片。
Can't make his deal. No, there's going to be one. Oh really? Lawrence Kasdan, the legendary director, is doing it for Imagine. Really? Wow, great. When does that, have you been shooting it? No, no, no, it's just they're just again,
谈不拢协议。不，会有一部的。哦真的吗？传奇导演劳伦斯·卡斯丹（Lawrence Kasdan）正在为Imagine公司制作这部片子。真的吗？哇，太棒了。那是什么时候——你们已经开始拍摄了吗？不，不，不，他们只是——目前他们只是在收集各种素材。
accumulating stuff at this point. Yeah, well that's gonna take years. Yeah, they're making the final decision on who it's about. Yeah. Yeah. They're trying to decide the ending. Yeah. How long are you in town, Marty?
是啊，那得花好几年时间。对，他们正在就这部片子到底该拍谁做最后决定。对。对。他们正试图决定结局怎么写。对。马蒂，你在城里呆多久？
Are you in? I go to New York in about two weeks for, you know, we start shooting. All right. And is it that, are you in the middle of production? We don't start shooting for two weeks. Yeah. A new season, I mean, or is it?
你在……我大约两周后去纽约，你知道的，我们要开始拍摄了。好的。那是——你们现在正处于制作中期吗？我们两周后才开始开拍。对。新的一季，我是说，还是说……
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We'll shoot a couple days in LA and then the bulk of it in New York. Okay, got it. And how are you guys enjoying the process of being locked onto a show that lasts, I mean, how long is your season to shoot? Four, five, six months?
对，对，对，对。我们会在洛杉矶拍几天，然后大部分在纽约拍。好的，明白了。你们觉得被锁在一部长寿剧里是一种怎样的体验？我是说，你们的一季要拍多久？四个月、五个月、六个月？
Yeah, four. It's about Four months, yeah, four. It's about four months, and I actually love it. It's, you know, the studio's 20 minutes from my house, and also you're working with two other co-stars, and so you're not shooting every day, and when we work together, it's really fun. And I would say that it is definitely Steve's philosophy, my philosophy,
对，四个月。大概四个月左右，对，四个月。大概四个月，我其实很喜欢。你知道的，工作室离我家只有20分钟路程，而且你是和另外两个联合主演一起工作，所以你不是每天都有戏份，当我们一起工作时，真的非常有趣。而且我可以肯定地说，这绝对是史蒂夫的哲学、我的哲学、
my philosophy, and it turned out, luckily, Selena's philosophy to make the set as much fun and joyful as it can be. So there are no pricks allowed. So it's fun to go to work. It's just stunning, right, how people don't enforce that rule commonly on a set because the hours that you work, the cast and the crew, are often
我的哲学，而且幸运的是，这也是塞琳娜的哲学——让剧组尽可能充满乐趣和欢乐。所以这里不允许任何混蛋存在。因此去上班是一件很开心的事情。这真的很惊艳，对吧？为什么人们通常不在剧组里严格执行这条规则呢？因为你们工作的小时数，演员和剧组人员，往往
many more hours than you spend with your family. So why would you tolerate anything short of a family dynamic on a set? Jamie, you've always been good about that. You're a crew guy and you've always had that rule, no pricks on set but me, and you've adhered to it, you've stuck by it, and you've never deviated, and there's only one.
比你陪伴家人还要多得多。所以你凭什么在剧组里容忍任何低于家庭氛围的东西？杰米，你一直以来在这方面都做得很好。你是个注重团队的人，而且你一直都有那个规矩：剧组里除了我之外不许有混蛋，你一直坚守这一点，从未违背，而且永远只有一个。
I've said this on the podcast before, but any job I get the very first day, say out loud to everybody, is if you look around and you can't find out who the asshole is, it's probably you. It's true. Well, you guys have been very, very nice to help us celebrate our 200th.
我在播客里说过这事，我接到的任何工作，第一天都会大声对所有人说：如果你环顾四周，却发现找不出谁是那个混蛋，那可能你就是。确实如此。好吧，你们俩真的非常非常好，来帮我们庆祝第200期。
I mean, this is a very significant booking. What a thrill. If we added up our ages, it'd probably be around that. What a thrill. Yeah. It'd be close. I worked with Jason in 2004, you know. And what?
我是说，这是一个非常具有里程碑意义的节目。太令人激动了。如果我们把大家的年龄加起来，大概也就是这个数字吧。太激动了。对。差不多吧。我2004年和杰森合作过，你知道的。还有什么？
And Will. Oh, unrested, yeah. Unrested, yeah. Unrested, I've never worn a wheelchair. Played a character, a rich fella, that had lost the use of his legs with a weightlifting accident and he was so wealthy that he, and hated wheelchairs,
还有威尔。哦，未完待续，对。未完待续，对。未完待续，我从来没坐过轮椅。我演过一个角色，一个超级有钱的家伙，在一次举重事故中失去了双腿，他太有钱了，而且讨厌轮椅，
he hired a big meathead, a big heavy fella to carry him around like a little baby. And then Marty would bark directions at him, you know. Shoot me! Yeah, shoot me, take me this way. To the nuts! And he'd have to dip him down to grab a handful of nuts. And then they did a flashback of the actual accident where he's lifting up a barbell, he puts it over his head,
他雇了一个膀大腰圆、壮硕敦实的壮汉像抱小婴儿一样把他抱来抱去。然后马蒂就会对那大汉大吼大叫下达指令，你知道的：“开枪打我！”对，“开枪打我，带我走这条路。往坚果那边走！”然后那壮汉就会把他往下放，好让他抓一把坚果。然后他们回放了那场真正的事故，当时他正举着杠铃，把它举过头顶，
and he just says, too much! And then his leg snapped underneath him. And then we cut back to the present time. It's one of the best. The funniest joke of that though was when, I'm being carried by Dragon, his name was. And I say, to the nuts! To the nuts! And he puts me at Jason's crotch.
然后他只是说：“太重了！”然后他的腿就在他身下折断了。接着镜头切回现在。这是最棒的桥段之一。不过其中最好笑的笑话是，当——我被一个叫德拉贡（Dragon）的壮汉抱着，他的名字叫德拉贡。然后我说：“往坚果那边走！往坚果那边走！”然后他把我塞到杰森的裆部。
And against his crotch I'm going, bridge mix! I want bridge mix! Where did Mitch, was that your joke or was it Mitch's? Mitch the Great Mitch Hurwitz? I think it must be Mitch's. Oh my God, the crap he'd come up with. Great Mitch Hurwitz. I remember doing My and Marty, the My and Marty show with Marty U. And we were rehearsing something in the hallway. And I said, should we just like, should we just kiss after that line? He said, yeah, let's do it. And he goes, let's rehearse it.
我贴着他的裆部喊着：“混合果仁！我要混合果仁！”米奇（Mitch）是从哪儿冒出来的，那是你的笑话还是米奇的？伟大的米奇·赫维茨（Mitch Hurwitz）？我觉得这肯定是米奇想出来的。天哪，他能想出那些破事。伟大的米奇·赫维茨。我记得我和马蒂做过那个《马蒂和我》节目，和马蒂·U一起。我们当时在走廊里排练某个桥段。我说：“我们要不要就在那句台词之后亲一下？”他说：“行啊，来吧。”然后他说：“我们排练一下。”
And he said, yeah, let's do it. And he said, yeah we just like, should we just kiss after that line? He said, yeah, let's do it. And he goes, let's rehearse it. And you just grabbed me and kissed me. There you go. Oh, he uses that a lot. I love that. Then I had to give you one note,
然后他说：“行啊，来吧。”然后他说：“我们是不是应该——就在那句台词之后亲一下？”他说：“行啊，来吧。”然后他说：“我们排练一下。”结果你直接把我抓过来就亲了。就是这样。哦，他经常这么干。我太喜欢了。后来我不得不给你提了一个小意见，
I just said, you know, it's a comedic kiss, we don't need the tongue. It was great. I mean, you and say, don't you ever get to see the people that you've been with? And you're like, oh, I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them.
我只是说：“你知道的，这是一个喜剧式的吻，我们不需要用舌头。”这太棒了。我是说，你和我说：“难道你从来没去看看那些你曾经合作过的人吗？”然后你会想：“哦，我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。
I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them.
我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。”
I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. I'm not gonna see them. And you guys are the two reasons you got into this business. I was literally gonna tease you, I was gonna joke and say don't you start crying, you're literally crying.
我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。我不会去看他们的。你们两个就是我入这行的原因。我本来想逗逗你们，开个玩笑说“你们可别哭啊”，结果你们真的哭了。
Yeah, because a lot of the times you don't have these moments. Yeah, I hear ya. We're very, very fortunate. I'm with you. We get to meet some real heroes on this show. Hands down, you two are the two reasons I got on this show.
对啊，因为很多时候你遇不到这种时刻。对，我懂你的意思。我们非常非常幸运。我赞同你。在这个节目里，我们有机会遇到真正的英雄。毫无疑问，你们两个就是我来这个节目的两大原因。
You're serious, aren't you? He is deadly serious. He's very soft and chewy on the inside. That's true. Thank you, Sean. It's true. You guys are incredible and incredibly generous to say yes to doing this today, so thank you.
你是认真的对吧？他是极其认真。他内心其实非常柔软细腻。确实如此。谢谢你，肖恩。千真万确。你们太棒了，而且非常慷慨地答应今天来做客，所以谢谢你们。
Thank you. I love your show. I love when you're joking around. It just feels like you're with three friends, you know, not you guys. But. I'm sure it's what you guys enjoy working together all these years, we certainly feel that way. And I remember I was on one of the early shows
谢谢。我喜欢你们的节目。我喜欢你们开玩笑的样子。感觉就像是和三个朋友在一起，你知道的，当然不是指你们。不过，我相信这也是你们这些年来一起工作所享受的乐趣，我们当然也有这种感觉。我记得我曾上过早期的一期节目
and you didn't even have a title yet. That's correct, that's true. And I suggested the Maguire Sisters. You did. Didn't clear. Didn't clear, didn't clear. We got so close. We got so close with that. Sorry for getting choked up there, but I meant it.
当时你们甚至连节目名字都还没定。没错，确实如此。我还建议叫“马奎尔姐妹”。你确实说过。没通过。没通过，没通过。我们差一点就定下来了。差一点就用那个了。为刚才情绪激动道个歉，但我绝对是真心实意的。
No, it's so, so thank you, Sean. That's why you are so lovely, because you were a hundred percent human being. Well, thanks, likewise. And he's got great taste. You guys are the best. Thanks, you guys. You guys are the best.
不，这很……所以谢谢你，肖恩。这就是你为什么这么可爱，因为你百分之百是个真性情的人。好吧，谢谢，彼此彼此。而且他眼光真好。你们俩最棒了。谢谢你们。你们俩是最棒的。
It is such a thrill for us. Thank you for having us. Thank you, guys. We loved it. Yeah. And I'll get the best, it is such a thrill for us. Thank you for having us. Thank you guys. We loved it. And I'll give you the address for the check. This will never air, this will never air, by the way. This will never. It can't.
这对我们来说真是莫大的激动。谢谢你们邀请我们。谢谢你们，伙计们。我们太喜欢了。对。我把支票寄到哪个地址最好，这对我们来说真是莫大的激动。谢谢你们邀请我们。谢谢你们，伙计们。我们太喜欢了。我来告诉你们支票寄到哪。这段绝对不会播出的，顺便说一句，绝对不会。不可能播的。
No, it can't. There's nothing usable. There's nothing. Yeah. You guys. We'll punch it up later. The great Mark Short and Steve Martin, my guys, thank you guys for doing our 200th episode.
对，不可能。没有一段能用的。根本没有。没错。伙计们。我们回头再加工一下。伟大的马丁·肖特和史蒂夫·马丁，我的哥们儿们，谢谢你们来参加我们的第200期节目。
What an honor. Thank you, brilliant show, love, have heard everyone. Loth episode. What an honor. Thank you, brilliant show. Love, have heard everyone. Love your show. Thank you. Love you, love you. Bye guys. Thank you guys.
真是莫大的荣幸。谢谢，精彩的节目，太棒了，听过每一个人的节目。第200期节目。真是莫大的荣幸。谢谢，精彩的节目。太棒了，听过每个人。喜欢你们的节目。谢谢。爱你们，爱你们。再见，伙计们。谢谢你们。
Thank you, bye bye. So I'm gonna say, I was at this dinner at our friend Ted's house. Yeah. And he had about 30 or 40 of the funniest people in his business. And I was fortunate enough to be there. And Dave Chappelle stands up,
谢谢，拜拜。所以我想说，我曾在我们朋友泰德家参加过一次晚宴。对。他邀请了这一行里大约三四十个最有趣的人。我有幸也出席了。然后戴夫·查佩尔站起来，
and he gives this incredible speech about how everybody in that room means something to him, and has meant something to him. And it was just incredible. I was blown away by his speech. And I thought, good on him for making that speech in the moment while it's happening. And so I had this conversation with myself. I'm like, do I say it? Do I wait till we're done?
发表了一场精彩绝伦的演讲，谈到在场的所有人对他的意义，以及曾经给予他的意义。简直太棒了。他的演讲让我惊叹不已。我想，真棒，他能在事情发生的当下就发表这样一番演讲。于是我内心开始了一番天人交战。我想：我要说出来吗？还是等我们做完节目再说？
And I say it to you guys and I was like, no, embrace the fear of saying that, the thing that you feel in front of the people you want to say it to. And so I seized the moment. It's just so lovely. And I guarantee you that just drilled them right in their heart and probably meant the world to them. Because I guarantee you they feel at least half of that going back to you. Yeah, and you know what, I will say this too, and I'm with you, that those two guys have had, or two people that I as well,
然后我对你们说出来，当时我想：不，要勇敢面对说出这些话的恐惧，把你内心的感受，当面告诉你想告诉的人。所以我抓住了这个时机。真的太美好了。我向你保证，这直击他们的内心深处，对他们来说可能意义重大。因为我向你保证，他们对你也有至少过半的同样感受。对，你知道吗，我也要这么说，我和你一样，那两个人，或者说这两个人，也是我……
have as a sort of comedic actor, if you will, I don't consider myself a comedian, but as a performer, two guys that I look up to as being at the sort of the pinnacle, again, gold standards of people that I think are funny, who have created funny things over the funny characters. For years. For years.
作为喜剧演员，如果你愿意这么称呼的话——我并不认为自己是个喜剧演员，但作为表演者——这两个人是我仰望的存在，他们可以说是金字塔尖，是那些我认为很有趣的人的黄金标准，他们多年来创造了无数有趣的事物、有趣的角色。多年来。多年来。
They have been relevant at the top of their game forever. And so the idea that I'm in a conversation with them, that they're doing our podcast, to me, is not, the novelty of that has not rubbed off. Right. And I hope it never does, right? And I never want to, right, and I never want to get to, ever,
他们一直处于行业顶端，长盛不衰。所以，一想到我能和他们对话，他们能来做我们的播客，对我而言……这种新鲜感至今未曾消退。没错。我希望它永远不会消退，对吧？我绝不想……对，我绝不想有一天，
get to a place in my life where I don't recognize things like that and I take them for granted. Because we've all been in this business for fucking 100 years, and you don't want to just pass moments by where we're like, oh yeah, there's so and so, there's so and so. It's like, you know them.
生活到了那种地步，我对这些事情习以为常，觉得理所当然。因为我们这群人都在这个该死的行业里混了一百年了，你可不想就这么让那些时刻从指缝间溜走，然后轻描淡写地说“哦，那是某某某，那是某某某”。就像是，你认识他们一样。
And it just takes a beat to go, wow, how did I get here? And those two guys are the only guy. As soon as a novelty wears off, you stop enjoying and appreciating how fortunate you are. I still remember, I think I was like, I don't know, 13 or 14 or something, and I'd been going for a couple of years,
只需要停顿一下，然后感叹：哇，我是怎么走到这一步的？而那两个人就是唯一的……一旦新鲜感消退，你就会停止享受和感激自己有多幸运。我还记得，我当时大概……我不知道，13或14岁左右吧，我已经入行几年了，
and one of my buddies at school said, well, what's the most famous person you've ever met? And I forget what I said, but I remember there was this was like one person that I thought, well, this would be a great answer. I still remember that like it was yesterday. And I think about it all the time on this show
学校里有个哥们儿问我：“好吧，你见过的最有名的人是谁？”我不记得当时怎么回答的，但我记得当时有一个人，我想：这绝对是一个超赞的回答。直到今天我还记得那件事，就像发生在昨天一样。在这个节目里我经常会想起这件事，
because we are so fortunate to be able to talk to people at the zenith of this business. And I feel, I mean, my pits are sweating right now. to talk to people at the zenith of this business. And I feel, I mean, my pits are sweating right now. They sweat every time we record this show. Because we're talking to someone that I don't feel like I really have a right to have on my show, our show.
因为我们太幸运了，能够与这个行业巅峰的人物对话。而且我……我是说，我现在的腋窝都在冒汗。能够与这个行业巅峰的人物对话。而且我……我是说，我现在的腋窝都在冒汗。每次录制这个节目时，我都会紧张得冒汗。因为我们在和这样的人对话——我觉得自己根本没有资格让他们上我的节目，我们的节目。
Like, what am I doing, hosting a show that they would be a guest on? It's just bizarre to me. JB, I played this thing yesterday, that thing that you could be at, and one of the guys I played with said to me, he said, oh man, when you guys had Bono on last year, and he knows Bono, he was like,
就像，我何德何能，居然能主持一个让他们来当嘉宾的节目？这对我来说简直太不可思议了。JB，我昨天打高尔夫时提到这事了，就是那种你可以参与的活动，和我一起打球的一个人对我说，他跟我说：“哦，天哪，你们去年请到博诺的时候……”他认识博诺，他说，
that was such a great interview, and Bono had such a great time, and he really felt really comfortable with you guys, and he really had such a great experience, and I'm thinking like, Bono told you that about hanging out with us fucking morons? Like what? Yeah, well, none of this is lost on us clearly.
“那真是一次太棒的采访，博诺玩得非常开心，他跟你们在一起真的感到很自在，有着一段极其美妙的经历。”我在想，博诺竟然对你说了这种话，关于跟我们这群该死的傻子一起混的事？就像什么？好吧，好吧，这些我们当然都心知肚明。
And no, we're lucky. We're fortunate. We're not lucky, but we're really fortunate. And as much joking as we do about our lives and all that kind of stuff that we get to do it, that we get the opportunities that kind of stuff, that we get to do it, that we get the opportunities to do it, and that we get to do it together. Yes, and now that we're talking about all this stuff
没错，我们很幸运。我们很幸运。虽然说不上是纯靠运气，但我们的确非常幸运。尽管我们总是拿自己的生活开玩笑，拿我们能做这份工作、能获得这些机会开玩笑——能从事这份工作，能获得这些机会，而且我们还能一起做这件事。是的，现在我们正在谈论所有这些事情，
on another level, that we get to do it together. And that I admire you guys and love you guys, just like I did them. It's really cool how those, yeah, and then those two guys, we were talking about it, that's why they're bopping around together, because they just love being with one another. Just like, we love being together
在另一个层面上，我们能够一起完成这些。而且我崇拜你们，深爱你们，就像我崇拜和爱他们一样。这真的很酷，那些……是的，然后那两个人，我们之前也在聊，这就是为什么他们总是一起到处晃悠，因为他们就是喜欢和彼此待在一起。就像我们喜欢聚在一起一样，
and how this whole thing started. It's so funny doing this thing, and we do it together, and people have opinions on it, and opinions on our relationships, and people come up to us and say stuff, or whatever. And it's odd, right? It's very kind of revealing sometimes. It was part of it that I never expected.
以及这一切是如何开始的。做这个节目太有趣了，我们一起完成它，人们对它有各种看法，对我们的关系有各种看法，人们会走到我们面前对我们说三道四，诸如此类。这很奇怪，对吧？有时甚至有点像在剥离我们的伪装。这也是我从未预料到的一部分。
Which one's the best? Which one's the funniest? No, but they talk about like what we do. And it's very, it's exposing in a way, right? In a way that I didn't anticipate before about being so open. And I feel very lucky, like you were saying, Sean, that I get to do it with you guys. I feel very safe doing it with you guys.
到底哪个最好？哪个最搞笑？不，但他们谈论的是我们的所作所为。某种程度上这很暴露，对吧？以一种我之前没有预料到的方式，赤裸裸地展现了这种坦诚。我觉得自己非常幸运，就像你刚才说的，肖恩，我能和你们一起做这件事。和你们一起做这件事让我感到非常安心。
And I love you guys a lot. And we, like anybody, we have moments that are tough as well and we do stuff and because we're friends and we're in business together and we do stuff. But as you know, we are, I think of you guys as my for real brothers and friends. And I love you guys a lot. I love you too.
我非常爱你们。而且我们，和所有人一样，也会经历艰难的时刻，我们会做一些事情，因为我们是朋友，又一起合伙做生意，我们会处理各种状况。但如你们所知，我认为你们就是我亲如手足的兄弟和朋友。我非常爱你们。我也爱你们。
And that we're doing this 200th episode, it's fucking crazy. Right. It is crazy. It's fucking crazy, dude. The other cool thing is that while we do hang out with each other away from this, this is not 50%, but it's, let's say 35%
我们居然在做这第200期节目，这他妈太疯狂了。没错。这确实太疯狂了。这他妈太疯狂了，老兄。另一个酷炫之处在于，虽然我们在私底下也会一起玩，但这并不是占了50%，而是大概占了……
of the time we spend with one another. And we shared this relationship, basically. We share 35% of our friendship with the people who are listening. So thank you guys for listening. Yeah, thank you guys. And thank you for being a part of whatever this three-headed beast is.
我们彼此相处时间的35%。基本上，我们与听众分享了这种关系。我们把35%的友谊分享给了正在收听节目的大家。所以谢谢你们收听。是的，谢谢大家。谢谢你们成为这个三头怪兽的一部分。
You see and you live with us 35% of our friendship, which is kinda cool. And so. It's been on a podcast called 35%. Willie, you started this podcast today kind of down. How do you feel now? I feel a lot better now. Good. It always works. Willie, you started this podcast today kind of down. How do you feel now? I feel a lot better now. Good.
你们见证并陪伴了我们35%的友谊，这挺酷的。所以。这个播客叫《35%》。威利，你今天录播客开始时情绪有点低落。你现在感觉怎么样？我感觉好多了。很好。这招总是管用。威利，你今天录播客开始时情绪有点低落。你现在感觉怎么样？我感觉好多了。很好。
It always works. Yeah, you do. It always does work. It always works, it's wild. You better fucking show up with the right attitude next time. No, I'm gonna show up as me every time. It's true.
这招总是管用。没错，确实如此。这招真的总是管用。这招一直管用，太疯狂了。下次你他妈最好带着正确的态度来。不，我每次都会以真实的自我来。确实如此。
Wherever I'm at. I don't try to flip a switch at all, right? We just open up the computer and away we go. Yeah, you're at where you're at, and it's true, like I even said, I anticipated that you start here and you can always end up up here. Always. Right, and that any day, any given day,
无论我处于什么状态。我根本不会去刻意切换状态，对吧？我们只是打开电脑，然后就开始录了。对，你在什么状态就是什么状态，确实如此，就像我刚才说的，我原本预料你从这里开始，最后总能达到这里的高度。总是这样。对，而且无论哪一天，在任何特定的一天，
doesn't have to be a bad day or a good day, you can have lots of different things on every day, and that's just the color of life. Yeah, you know, people come and go, you say hello, you say. Yeah. Yeah, you know people come and go, you say hello, you say... Bye, bye. You say goodbye.
不一定非得是糟糕的一天或美好的一天，每天你都可以经历许多不同的情绪，那就是生活的斑斓色彩。对，你知道的，人来人往，你说声嗨，你说……对。对，你知道人来人往，你说声嗨，你说……再见，再见。你说拜拜。
Bye, bye. Boy, I wish we had some of those recommendations for buys. Right now. Right now. Will, are you trying to Google one right now? We went to... We went before, we were just gonna say a bi. I feel like there's something we could do
拜拜。天哪，我真希望现在能有一些关于“买入”的推荐。就在现在。就在现在。威尔，你现在是在用谷歌搜索吗？我们之前去……我们本来想说个“双”（bicentennial）。我觉得我们可以搞点
like in a bicentennial type of thing because it's 200 years. Do it, Jay, it's our bicentennial, do it. It is our, this is happy bi- Bicentennial! Is it really bicentennial? Yeah. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant
类似两百周年庆纪念那种东西，因为我们迎来了200期。搞吧，杰伊，这是我们的两百周年庆，搞吧。这就是我们的，这是快乐的双——双周年庆！真的是两百周年吗？是的。聪明。聪明。聪明。《SmartLess》由班尼特·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·
Terry and Rob Armjarf. SmartLess If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wonder.com slash survey. Hello, I'm Johnny Knoxville and I'm Elna Baker and we have a new podcast is called Pretty Sure I Can Fly. Yep, we've teamed up with my friends and bar mates from smart list to create a podcast where we talk to folks who
特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫100%纯天然手工制作。SmartLess 如果你喜欢《SmartLess》，现在就可以加入Wondry App或Apple Podcasts上的Wondry Plus，提前收听无广告版。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上免广告收听。在离开之前，请在wondry.com/survey填写简短问卷，告诉我们您的想法。大家好，我是约翰尼·诺克斯维尔，我是埃尔娜·贝克尔，我们有一个新播客叫《我挺确信我能飞》。是的，我们与我在《SmartLess》的朋友兼酒吧酒友们联手打造了一个播客，在这里我们与
have more balls in a bowling alley. People who accomplish something extraordinary despite people telling them that it couldn't or shouldn't be done. You'll hear stories about the Air Force doctor who buckled into a 600 mile per hour rocket sled and became the fastest man on the planet. And a man who wrestles alligators and sharks for fun. Do not do this.
比保龄球馆还要有卵子的人对话。这些人取得了非凡的成就，尽管当时所有人都告诉他们这不可能或不应该做到。你会听到这样的故事：空军医生将自己绑在时速600英里的火箭雪橇上，成为了地球上速度最快的人。还有一个为了好玩而与短吻鳄和鲨鱼搏斗的男人。千万不要模仿。
You'll hear about a foul mouth moonshiner. Got a two inch dick and a six inch tongue and knows how to use both of them. And an even more foul-mouthed female stunt pilot. We got bull riders, balloonists, bops letters, and big wave surfers. People who lay their balls on an anvil and hand the other fellow the hammer. I bet you've actually done that, Johnny. Maybe for sweeps. Follow Pretty Sure I Can Fly on the Wondery app. Or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Pretty Sure I Can Fly early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你会听到一个满嘴脏话的私酒贩子。“他有一根2英寸的鸡巴和6英寸长的舌头，而且知道怎么两样都用。”还有一个说话更难听的女性特技飞行员。我们采访过斗牛士、热气球飞行员、高空跳伞员和大浪冲浪者。这些是将命豁出去，把铁锤交到别人手里的人。我敢打赌你真的干过这事，约翰尼。也许是为了节目收视率吧。在Wondry App上关注《我挺确信我能飞》，或者在你获取播客的任何地方收听。你可以提前收听《我挺确信我能飞》本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。